What's up humanoids.
It is I, Rich Roll, in cahoots with one Mr. Skolnick,
content creator, sir, Adam Skolnick.
Here to corrupt your neurochemistry with ideas,
big and small.
Good to be here with all of you.
In addition to breaking down sundry matters of interest
and perhaps disinterest.
Yes.
We also do a little bit of show and tell here,
a couple of wins of the week and we round it all out
by answering some of the questions dropped on our voicemail
which you can ring up at (424) 235-4626.
Before we dive in, if you're watching at www.youtube.com,
have you heard of this thing, YouTube, Adam?
I've heard it's the new thing.
It's the thing, right?
If you add the backslash Rich Roll, you will arrive
at a channel wherein we upload videos
directly from this podcast.
Take a second to hit subscribe. That would mean a lot.
Click that notification bell, it will alert you
when a new podcast goes live.
Click the like button and of course, leave a comment
with your thoughts, because that's what we do here.
How are you doing, man?
Careful, careful how you answer this question.
A lot of consternation in the comments.
Well, yes, the comments have said, I always respond
the same way with, I'm good man.
You do, right? I'm good, man. I'm good.
Which makes people think that I'm either doing well
or like...
Disingenuous.
Or just hanging on, barely hanging on, man.
Yeah. I don't know, that I'm good, man.
It just feels, it's a false flag.
First of all, it's grammatically incorrect.
I mean, if I can just...
I'm well, man.
Yeah, I'm very well, man, that doesn't sound as...
Who's the man in this sentence?
You're the man, right?
It's the Rich Roll podcast.
All right. So how are you actually doing.
I'm actually been living with doubt. How have you been?
Don't throw it right back at me
without elaborating on that.
I've been living with doubt.
So I'm in the third draft of this novel
that I've been wanting to write for a long time.
And the entire time of writing it,
has felt like I'm out of my depth, which is normal, right?
Cause I'm not, I wrote a novel once previously,
this is the third crack.
I attempted to write a novel way way back in the 90's
and convinced myself I sucked
and shouldn't be writing a novel.
And so I stopped.
When in reality I went back later several years later
and read the pages and it was pretty good
and I should have kept going.
But by then I wanted to do this other book, finish that,
that book is actually how I got Byrd to represent.
Right.
Our agent.
For "One Breath".
For "One Breath", Byrd Leavell, shout out.
And so then "One Breath" ended up happening
but the novel itself never found a home.
It was like one of those, almost but not quites.
And so then this other novel I've been thinking about
since then, and just never made the time to do it.
And so the quarantine happened and I started to do it
and now I'm on a third pass.
I think it's going to be like 10 passes
before I give it to anyone to look at.
And it just feels like, you know,
we've talked about this stuff.
It just feels like the imposter syndrome is strong
because I'm wading into territory
that hasn't been my territory.
And even though I've, you know, comfortable writing
books now, and I'm comfortable with my work,
there's things about this that make it a little bit harder
for me to really see it.
And so I'm just sticking with the process,
trusting the process.
But I can't say that I'm not living with doubt.
Like every day I sit down to do it, it's like,
I wondering if it's any good, which is not abnormal.
When I write a story for the New York times,
I feel the same way, the first draft.
Yeah, and doubt is a kindred cousin of humility
on some level.
Like if you weren't experiencing doubt then I would be,
you know, prone to believe that that, you know,
you were in your ego, like how could you not have doubt?
Of course you have doubt.
It's not a function of doubt,
it's allowing the doubt to stop the progress.
Right.
It's like persevering in the face of doubt.
Having the courage to continue to show up for the page.
Yeah, I think I read Stephen King interview
in the New York times magazine some time ago.
And he said that's part of what we get paid to do,
is to not give into that.
And so...
Yeah, I think that's really helpful.
So in that same interview, he's like,
he's only had one book where he didn't feel that way
about the book the entire time.
Right, because you just assume he sits down
and bangs it out and it's like a work of art in draft one.
Most successful novelist in the history of, I think,
in the history of American writers, I think so,
in terms of books sold and everything and movies made.
So anyway, so there's that, but at the same time
I do enjoy the process at times.
But it's still a process of getting comfortable
with the doubt and living in this fantasy land in my head.
So that's how I've been.
And at the same time raising a child which is also,
the doubt is strong.
There's that.
And in between all of that trying to find some time
to slowly saunter down into the sea, adorn your face mask.
My full mask.
Submerge yourself and do a zone zero workout.
I'm doing either zone two runs or zone zero swims.
That's where I live.
I did find out, have you heard of the Malibu artist
on Instagram?
No.
So he's been getting some mainstream media play.
He was on the cover of the LA times.
Then he was on the Today's show.
He's a drone photographer and he is, I've talked to him
this week because basically he's been posting
great drone footage of great white sharks in Malibu
everywhere from sunset point.
he hasn't specified where these places are.
But many, like in one video,
there are 22 juvenile white sharks within 50 feet
of surfers, swimmers.
Wow.
And that they have no idea that they're there.
And so obviously being someone who swims, I mean,
I knew Sunset Point was, I've seen
a white shark breach there as I was just driving
down the highway.
And I've seen one breach by Little Dume as well.
So I knew that they're there and we've talked about it.
I know they're there.
But it actually makes me feel a little more comfortable
because the sharks are not at all interested
in these swimmers whatsoever.
It's one way to look at it.
That's how I look at it.
So, and I talked to him, he basically,
he deals with certain landowners who allow him to come on
and he's able to fly the drone.
He is not at Point Dume too much, although he said
the biggest shark he's ever seen was at Point Dume.
Right, probably right at that point on roots
of Little Dume that you took me on, that everybody said,
stay away from there.
Yeah, that's the one, like a 14 foot or something.
Yeah, oh my God.
Great white?
Yeah, they're always white sharks that he's finding
that he's at least putting up.
I think he has some Orca footage he's gonna put up.
It's at the Malibu artist on Instagram, it's cool footage.
I mean, he's really, he does a good job.
So he got on the today show
because people are freaking out that there's so many sharks
right off the shoreline.
Yeah, and because you know, this is a big year for sharks.
So I've talked to one of my contact, Laura Bodmer,
who brought me the story about Travis Rice's
snowboarding competition.
She's lives down in San Diego area, North County.
And she said that right now, Solana beach it's like,
they know about the juvenile white sharks.
They are actually seeing them a lot.
No one's getting hurt.
Is it like an unusually large spawn that like...
Yeah, it's just different populations are healthy.
You know, like the Marine protected areas are working
and the populations are healthy.
I think that's part of it.
I mean, they're studying it.
So I'm not exactly sure if there's anything to why,
but this is just what's happening.
And so, but so far, like we haven't had an uptick in attack.
Like it isn't leading anywhere bad.
So I don't think there's anything to be worried about.
For me it makes me feel actually more comfortable
to be on it, in some weird counterintuitive, intuitive way.
I don't know if I am processing it in the same way.
(both laughing)
Well the Smithsonian just did a story, which we can link
to how great white sharks and all sharks
might use magnetics to navigate.
Whoa.
There was this cool, a cool story about some scientists
that put a certain breed of shark, bonnethead sharks
I think, in a tank that they wired with copper wires
and they basically took the magnetic,
the magnetic coordinates or whatever it's called.
Basically the earth is got, you know, iron ore
and all sorts of metals and heavy metals.
And that's what, the core of those metals,
they think sharks are using to get from point A to point B.
As a navigation anchor.
As a navigation tool.
And they proved it with this tank by wiring wires
and, you know, putting readouts like that would be
the magnetic draw from their home
versus the magnetic draw from away.
And they managed to swim in the direction
of the proper magnetic draw.
And yes, cause great white sharks go out
into the middle of the ocean to some place called
the great white cafe or something like that,
the scientists call it.
And they've got this huge congregation.
It's like Burning Man for white sharks,
in the middle of the ocean.
And everyone tried to figure out how do they get there,
know to go there and then know where they're going
to go home, and they think it's magnetic.
Right? There's some kind of beacon.
Yeah.
In the core of the earth that's luring them
to this one place.
That's wild.
Isn't that cool?
Yeah.
So maybe there's right now it's being...
Only white sharks?
I know they think all sharks, they think hammerheads,
they're thinking all sharks.
But this particular experiment only proves it with this
one small subset.
All right, it makes you wonder whether that's applicable
for other species as well.
Like bird migration patterns.
Like how do these animals that travel vast distances
and always find their way home.
Figure that out.
Even cats.
Sea turtles.
A buddy of mine took his cat camping in Mammoth
and he was living in Santa Monica at the time,
took his cat to Mammoth.
The cat ran off in the middle of the night camping.
They had to leave.
They couldn't find the cat.
They figured the cat was dead.
Like got eaten by a coyote or something.
Two weeks later, the cat walks in his front door.
No way.
I swear to God
For people that don't know, Mammoth is a couple
of hundred miles away.
How is that possible?
I don't know.
It didn't have a tag with an address on or anything?
No, the cat was all fucked up, it was like it had gone
on a weird...
And it found its way home?
Pippin the cat, shout out.
I feel like that should be a Pixar movie.
That's unbelievable.
The Odyssey starring Pipping the cat.
All right, well, we're off to a banger of a star here
with the podcast.
I like it so far.
Yeah. How are you Rich?
I'm good.
I'm rocking my taco Vega T-shirts so.
Yeah, talk to me about taco Vega.
I've never even heard about it.
You've got to go to Taco Vega, man.
It's the new spot in Los Angeles.
Taco Vega is a plant-based Mexican themed restaurant
in Los Angeles.
It's right on Fairfax, like a block or two South of Melrose.
So kind of right in the heart of this,
for people that don't know that strip of Fairfax
is like where Canter's deli is.
And there's all these like hypey stores,
like Supreme and rip and dip,
so a lot of kids in that neighborhood.
And it's really high-end but affordable,
like really creative Mexican food
by my friend, chef, owner, Jared Simons.
Who's a super cool guy.
He's also coached by Chris Health.
Oh really?
Yeah. He's an Ironman athlete.
Now he's focusing on ultra running, really colorful,
interesting, sweet guy that I've known over the years.
So I've been a frequent visitor of Taco Vega over the last,
I think I've been like five times in the last month.
I love it.
Fantastic.
So if you're in Los Angeles, drop in, say hello to Jared,
tell him that we sent you.
He's really a great chef.
Interesting story about that, that he reminded me of,
that I forgot about when I saw him the other day,
he actually, Jared actually catered a wedding at our house
a couple of years ago.
We sometimes rent our house out for weddings for friends.
And this wedding was, our friend Maddie Serpico,
shout out to Maddie, who is a former, she's a Canadian,
former triathlete vegan and she got married
to Griff Whalen who's been on the podcast
back in the early days, a former Stanford NFL,
Indianapolis Colts, kind of journeyman wide receiver
who's also vegan, a friend of the podcast.
They got married at our house and Griff's groomsmen
were all like gigantic humans who had played in the NFL
or at Stanford, including Andrew Luck,
who was like his best man.
Like so, Andrew Luck is like Griff's best friend
from college, then they played together in the pros
for a while.
So Andrew Luck was like at my house, you know,
playing with my boys and throwing a football around
and like, yeah.
Amazing.
And I wasn't there. I was out of town.
Shout out to Andrew Luck.
I was unable to seize the opportunity to meet Andrew Luck.
Although he did visit my home.
One day he's gonna be telling the time that he threw
the football around with the rockstars.
I don't think so.
I don't think that's ever occurred to him.
But he's welcome back at my home anytime.
He's also welcome to drop in on the podcast
if he ever wants to share a story.
Yeah.
It would be cool.
What a great athlete.
Switching gears a little bit, I've been told,
I've been chastised in the comment section
to stop being mean to you.
Really?
Yeah.
To me?
I think because I was beating up on you a little bit
about the face mask, the surgical mask.
That was tongue in cheek.
That's what I thought.
Am I being mean? you can tell me.
Right now?
It's all in love.
Wait, wait a second.
Wait, am I having an interview?
No, If I'm being too mean to you, I want you to tell me.
You know what?
I think everyone needs to stop being offended
by almost everything.
Thank you.
Yeah, so no, I have not at all thought
you've been mean to me.
It's all, we're trying to entertain people.
I don't know if we're succeeding.
We're trying.
The fact is I wear a mask when I'm swimming.
It is off putting.
When I showed up at Catalina to do the swim run,
there was one guy wearing a mask.
Most people had goggles.
Right.
I had the mask.
And that was your moment to kind of learn a little bit
about how the ecosystem works.
Apparently that didn't, it was not effective though,
in getting you to change your habit.
No, but...
Well, it's the affinity for it.
It defies logic, I don't understand your illogical,
irrational attachment to your snorkel mask.
It's not called a snorkel mask.
I don't know what it's called.
But it has no place.
It has no place in a swim run lineup.
Correct.
So the reason is because the etymology of the mask
is that I was wearing those bigger
kind of open-water goggles for a while.
And then we started to do more diving on our swims
at Big Dume or at Westward to Point Dume.
And then I got into this free diving,
kind of looking into free diving as a journalist
and started doing that story and the book.
And pretty quickly I was told that, no, you can't free dive
with goggles because you can't equalize goggles.
You can't fill the space.
So if you go too deep your eyeballs are going to bulge
and it's gonna be, you could break a blood vessel
and you could have problems.
And so you have to have something
that you can let a little air out through your nose
to equalize that small space.
And the lower profile you have, the better
you can equalize that, because if you have too much space
like a scuba diving mask, you can't fill that space.
So, you know, with limited, unless you have a big tank
on your back.
And so, they're all used for training
this particular kind of free dive mask.
I get it, I get it.
Sure. But here's the thing.
Are you a free diver or are you a swim run person?
Pick your lane.
It's a very good question.
Or at least if you're going out for a swim run workout,
wear goggles.
Well, the real question is, are you an open water swimmer
or are you a free diver?
And I submit that neither tribe will embrace me.
Right, because you're waffling between these two worlds.
You gotta plant your foot firmly in one.
At least like, okay, I'm going out for a free dive,
then you can wear that and say I'm free diving.
But if you're just going out for a swim,
leave the mask at home.
Get goggles.
Yeah.
I might do it because Julie Shakeya, who swims with us,
who you've swam with, she's one of the actual swimmers
that swims with us.
And she actually goes for her swims in the morning,
then comes meets us for our swims and dives.
She does think that it slows you.
Like when she's doing a swim only, she wears goggles.
And she does think the mask slows you down.
Right, I love how she's your reference point
after I've been beating you up over this forever.
It's like, oh, but she said, okay.
Do I have to start a change.org petition
to get you to abandon this practice?
Do you think it's slowing me down?
Of course.
Oh you do?
But mainly it's making you look silly when you need not.
I like looking silly.
Yes. I know.
Am I being too mean?
No.
I'm not being too mean.
This is entertaining.
All right, we'll check in on this week to week.
It's going to be a new segment.
Can I confront you with something?
Congratulations on 600 episodes.
Thank you.
That's a big accomplishment.
It's crazy.
I don't know how we got here.
You know, it's just a one day at a time thing, you know
and then you look up and you're like, whoa, 600 episodes.
That's crazy.
Unbelievable.
I know.
It seems like a past life when we started
and it seems like yesterday.
Did you do any reflecting?
Like when you have these numbers come around,
is it every a hundred that you kind of think about,
wait a second.
Like, did you think about it at a hundred or 200 or?
I thought it more at a hundred and at 200
than I did with 600 and I'm like, oh, that's cool.
Moving on. What's next?
Always look forward.
Right.
It's great, I think it's important to pause
and celebrate that a little bit, but I don't dwell
on these things.
I remember early on in the show,
when we would hit certain benchmarks,
like when we hit our first 1 million downloads
or whatever it was, I would make a big deal out of it.
And now it's just like, yeah, that's cool.
Let's keep going.
Nice.
So I don't spend a lot of time reflecting on that
because it's not really about that.
Right.
It's just about being in the process of doing it.
It's just creating content, so.
That's right.
You know this now as a content creator.
Yes.
Sir Adam Skolnick.
That's what I've become now, a content creator?
You are a content creator.
That's good because then...
It's a weird thing though, because especially
as an author and a writer and a journalist,
it's like content, seems like a step down.
We are in a content creator economy now.
Yeah, I mean, I think that less and less people
are reading books, which is a true thing.
But then again, and that was reflected in the fact that
like what, 92% of all books released in the last year
and a half or something sold less than 10,000 copies.
But books actually sold very well.
Yeah, books are selling great.
But it's known quantity books.
It's like three-year-old, five-year-old books
or, you know, big name, authors.
But I think Amazon and the Kindle hearkened this idea
that it was sounding the death knell for books.
And it's been quite the opposite.
Audio books are off the chain.
Audio books are great.
I do listen to audio books and I read print books.
I had a Kindle that I used a lot when I was traveling
so many months out of the year.
It just became easier, but it's collected a lot of dust.
Yeah.
I like the hard copy and I like the audio books.
Same.
Yeah. But 600 is great.
We celebrated that by putting up the episode
with Matthew Walker, which people are enjoying,
up last night, we we're recording this on Monday.
Three hours.
Three hours on sleep. He's the dude
I've got to dive into that.
Although I'll feel like shamed, because right now
sleep is not coming in.
Right, I mean, if you're a new parent
and you've lost your grip on healthy sleep hygiene,
it might just make you feel bad.
It'll make you feel alarmed, I think.
Yeah, I think so. I think so
But he's such a beautiful, gentle, wise person.
And the way that he communicates it's a cool thing.
He's very talented at explaining the science
behind all of this stuff in a manner in which you can
not only understand it but actually become encouraged
and enthusiastic about taking sleep
a little bit more seriously.
So that's really cool.
Very cool.
That's a conversation I wanted to have
for a very long time.
So, excited that we finally made that happen.
And just been banking some other cool episodes.
I had Mary Cain here last week, who many might recall
from a New York times, op doc, she was the the title
of that piece, was something like,
I was the fastest girl in America and then I joined Nike
and it's her story of training under Alberto Salazar
and everything that happened.
And she was a wonderful guest.
I'm excited about that.
I'm trying to book Maggie Baird right now,
who's Billie Eilish's mom.
We've been going back and forth.
Hopefully we can lock in on a date.
I think she would be Epic.
Did you watch the Billie Eilish documentary?
I did not watch it yet, no.
It's fantastic.
I mean, I am actually, I really enjoy Billie Eilish's
point of view and her music, so.
She is a force.
Yeah.
It's a really instructive documentary
that's incredibly well done.
That gives you a glimpse into, you know,
the birth of this amazing talent, but it's also in tandem,
a parenting documentary.
Because it documents the period of time leading up
to the release of her first album and her brother Phineas
and her literally record the album in his bedroom,
while they're living in their parents' house
as homeschooled young people.
And you see the interaction of the parents
and how the parents are trying to support,
responsibly support their children
through this incredibly unique period of time
in which they're introduced to the world
in the largest way imaginable.
Like everything just explodes.
And it's a very well done documentary.
She's cool, Maggie is really cool.
I don't know how old she is now.
When she broke out.
Yeah, I think she was about 17, well,
"Ocean eyes" came out when she was like 13 or 14
or something like that and blew up.
And that's what led to everything.
It's like, Lord, first album.
Yeah. It's amazing.
And you know, just a truly, uniquely gifted person
and Phineas is the engine behind it.
Like he writes, at a minimum co-writes
but I think he wrote a lot of the songs
and he really engineers and produces the music.
It's very collaborative, but you realize how instrumental
he is to the whole thing as well.
And their relationship as brother and sister and also
you know, partners in creativity is super interesting.
Older brother?
Older brother, yeah.
Who also has all kinds of solo work that he does as well.
And Maggie, you know, they're big plant-based vegan
advocates and activists as well.
So I'm excited to sit down with her.
Hopefully.
That's awesome.
Soon to check that out.
Yeah. Let's check in on the Iron Cowboy.
Don't you wish we could just call him, like,
at some point we should just, next time let's call him
while he's out riding the bike.
And like really check in on the Iron Cowboy.
We could do that.
I think maybe we could schedule that.
Which should be cool.
Yeah.
Call him and then drop it in as a segment.
Yeah, yeah.
I think he'd be down for that.
One of the things that I did do the other day
and this is a credit, shout out to Brogan Graham,
our third co-host here in absentia.
He's the Elijah of this podcast.
He is, but one of the things,
I can't remember whether I talked about this
on the podcast before or not.
Or I might've talked about it on a podcast
that hasn't gone up yet.
But one of the amazing things about Brogan
that's kind of an outgrowth of his predisposition
towards extrovertism is in addition to being
like just the most outgoing person you're ever gonna meet,
he has a practice of connecting with friends by texting them
what he calls short films.
So video messages essentially,
but he would berate me for that title there.
Short films.
They are short films.
And he will every single day send me a little short film
of him checking in.
And they're usually well staged with props and all kinds
of stuff that have a story arc to them and kind of end
with, you know, something prolific or poignant.
And I've adopted this practice and started doing it.
Like I started sending short films to other friends of mine
and it's kind of a cool way in an age in which
we don't write letters anymore,
which is another thing Brogan does.
He sends the letters out on an old typewriter.
Oh, that's cool.
Which is another cool practice.
But to connect with friends, like, you know,
it's that thing where you haven't talked to somebody
for a long time, you're like, ah, do I have 40 minutes
to call them?
And then you don't and then the phone gets really heavy.
This way you can send a short film, check in with them.
There's no expectation that they need to get back to you
but you're demonstrating that you're thinking about them
or you know, you have something you want to impart.
And it's kind of a cool unique thing
that I think more people should do.
So I started doing it more.
You and I are on a group text with Brogan.
So you've been doing that with him.
So I sent one of these two.
They are on cowboy last week, just wishing him well,
which you know, he got back to me, It's cool.
So I think he would be down for a call.
I think that would be great.
He's gotta be on his bike right now, right?
It's almost one o'clock here in LA.
He's probably finishing his ride.
Today is day 71 today, we're recording on Monday,
this goes up on Thursday.
So we're on day 71.
He seems to be in very good spirits
He's doing great.
It's like he rounded a corner and he's smiling
and laughing and joking with people
and in a really good spot.
It's unbelievable.
I wonder what's happening to him.
Unbelievable.
70 Ironmans into this thing.
70 in a row, one after another.
No break.
No break. No day off
No break for Mother's day.
No.
There was one day last, I think it was last week.
His daughters were going to prom, so he stopped for a photo
and like wish them well, like saw his daughters off to prom
and during T2, in between his bike and his marathon.
That's hilarious.
And it seems like more and more people are congregating
to join him.
And I love, in the video that I sent him I said,
there's two things that I really love and appreciate
about how he's conducting himself through this whole thing.
The first is just the participatory nature of this
and we've talked about this before.
It's a very inclusive thing.
Like he's really engendered a lot of community
around what he's doing.
All comers are welcome. He makes them feel welcome.
It's not like, hey, I'm over here, stay away from me.
It's like, we're all in this together kind of vibe.
And then at the conclusion of every marathon, every evening,
everybody kind of surrounds him in a circle
and he gives a little impromptu speech
and he recognizes certain people who came out to join him.
I think his son did the marathon, marathon 70 with him.
He recognized him or people that fly in from out of town.
My friend, Chris Guillebeau, flew in from Portland
to do a day with him.
Like people are coming from all over to get a taste of this.
And the fact that he, in his exhaustion still, you know,
takes that moment to recognize them,
I think is really special.
And it speaks to, you know,
fundamentally his good character.
Unbelievable. Do you feel like, 'cause he's doing like 15
to 16 minute mile marathons, like do you feel
like he's doing like walk five minutes, run five minutes.
I think he's pretty much walking the whole way.
And I believe he said, you know, look, I wish I could run.
I think that his ankles or whatever's going on with his hips
or whatever, he's unable to run.
So he's literally just walking so that, you know,
people should know, it's like, yeah,
ideally he would be running all these marathons,
but he's like, you know, I think he's a very good walker
in that when you develop that skill, you can walk
quite a bit faster than people realize.
And probably faster than an easy jog and certainly faster
than the Ironman shuffle.
But I think it's pretty much a brisk walk
at this point every day.
Which takes him like over six hours I think.
That's crazy.
I mean, it's amazing.
And you know, speaking of his, just his ethics
and his charisma, you wanted to talk about this,
the fact that the Ironman's triathlon governing body
was coming at him and how he responds to that.
I mean, he's, to be in the midst of this
and have to deal with that and then to deal with it
in a way that still is, he could have been so much more
bent out of shape and he really wasn't.
He was just like...
He put his foot down though.
He made no bones about where he stands on this whole thing.
So we should explain.
He got into a beef with Iron man.
Iron man sent him essentially a cease and desist letter
indicating that because there's a lot of press now
that's occurring around what he's doing, CNN
and all these newspapers are covering what he's doing.
And apparently in some of these pieces, they're saying
that he's doing a hundred Iron mans.
Iron man is a trademark of the WTC, they're very protective.
and they police that trademark pretty rigorously.
So he gets this email, basically says, look,
all this press is covering you.
They're calling what you're doing a hundred Iron mans,
just so we're clear, Ironman is a protected mark
that we own and control.
Please refrain from using that.
And please let them know that they can't use that.
He's like, and he screen grabbed it,
he shared it on Instagram, and his caption
was essentially like, I don't have time for this.
Like, you've got a problem with the press outlets,
go contact them.
I'm out here breaking world records every single day.
And by the way, like I'm doing more for your brand
than anybody, raising awareness around this thing.
And you're coming at me, like I'm done with you.
And by the way, you owe me like $4,000 for, you know,
unrefunded race entry fees and things like that.
Like he basically just,
he just basically, you know, slapped them across the face.
He did.
But in a way that was like, kind of, I think,
positive for what he's doing.
He's like, you know, he's like, he's not going to take shit,
but it wasn't whiny.
It was just straight up, you know, like sometimes
that could be, you could come off worse.
And I thought that he did,
I thought that his statement was fantastic.
Yeah, and I think in a broader way it speaks to the ills
of the corporatization of multi-sport.
You know, come on Iron man, like a bunch of lawyers
had to like write this letter.
It's causing a backlash in reverse of what they're trying
to do, which is to engender support for their brand, right?
And that was James's point, is that, look, you know,
you say you're all about inclusion
and you're about inspiration.
And I'm out here trying to do both of those things
and you're telling me to stop or to do it differently.
Like, how dare you, like I'm done with you.
Right. It's...
You have to wonder who is like in charge
of writing that letter, like who is...
There was some C-suite person who just called up
the general councils department at the organization
and said, look, you know, we gotta clear this up, you know?
And then that's how it lands, come on.
It landed poorly, very tone deaf from the Iron man,
the WTC.
Right. And imagine if you flip the switch
or flip the lens on it, and Ironman came to his support
and said, we love what you're doing, it's fantastic.
Keep going. Do you need any support? How can we help you?
Exactly.
And the Goodwill that that would engender
for the larger organization as a whole.
And if you have an issue with the fact
like what he's doing isn't exactly how it would go
in an Iron man race, you can use that platform to say so.
Sure.
Yeah.
But to say, hey, we don't like what you're doing.
Stop talking about it in the way
that you're talking about it.
And contact the media company.
Behind that is this idea that oh, no,
if people start doing their own adventures,
they're not going to sign up for our races.
All those races sell out anyway.
Right. They can't.
So what are you really talking about?
I mean, right now, the fact is that like,
we're just coming out of it.
It was hard to stage these races.
You couldn't stage the races
and people had to do virtual races.
But as someone who has done a few of these virtual events.
And they canceled all their races
and didn't refund anybody their entry fees.
Is that right?
Yeah, so that's what he's talking about.
That's, you know, a big thing that a lot of people
are grousing about.
And the issue of corporatization of multi-sport
was also, you know, switching gears a little bit
in the news this past week, because Ironman partnered
or took a minority stake in UTMB,
the Ultra-Trail du Mont Blanc, which is really
the sports trail running most prestigious week-long series
of ultra marathons.
And this has ruffled quite a few feathers.
The UTMB is like this Epic race. And it's a big race.
A lot of, you know, a lot of trail runs,
there's not very many people in them.
They're very kind of grassroots but UTMB is, you know,
a huge event.
So a lot of people are kind of decrying the commodification
of the trail ultra world.
They're going to create this UTMB world series.
You're going to have to qualify.
The big fear of course being that all these big
corporate sponsors are going to roll in,
entry fees are going to go through the roof.
Not everybody though, there's certain, you know,
well-known athletes who are supportive of this move
but I think, there's a guy called John Kelly
who's done a lot Ironmans and has also done
a lot of trail races.
And he said, monopolization of events
through exclusive qualifiers to the premier, quote, unquote,
premier race, leading to sky-high entry fees
and closure of independent races, complete disregard
for host sites, athlete experience and safety or anything
in the way of money, you know,
there's different cultures and goals.
So it really is, and basically what he's saying is,
there's a clash of cultures here.
And I think that's right.
You know, when you think of Ironman you think of people
who show up, they look the part,
they're wearing a certain kind of costume, you know,
they got the right tattoo.
It's a culture that's very different and at odds
with the trail running culture, which is much more
of a down to earth.
It's a dirt bag, much more dirt bag.
Yeah, those are the roots of it.
At the same time, I suppose partnerships like this
are inevitable as the exposure and the growth of sports
like trail running continue to grow, right?
This is gonna happen.
So if it is gonna happen, how do you do it correctly
and properly and preserve what's great
about the trail running culture and not let it
become corrupted by the influx of cash.
I don't know, we'll find out, I guess.
I mean, that's one of the draws of Attila, right?
Is that those guys are so not corporate.
You know, so imagine the response if suddenly you woke up
and you got an email from Attila saying they partnered
with Ironman.
Like it wouldn't make sense to me.
No, 'cause they seem like completely different.
That's what you're saying.
Not block thing is yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, no, it wouldn't make sense.
I don't foresee that happening but...
I don't either, but I think a lot of people
would have said there's no way that UTMB
would partner with Ironman.
Well then, what's in it for them?
Do you think just some steak money?
I think stability, cash, you know, the ability to plug
into a really well-funded machine that knows how to
like blow these things up and create structure for them.
And a big brand, right?
The big brand, it's easy to raise money off a brand. Right?
Sure, but from what I understand, there will be no Ironman
branding at UTMB.
So it appears that UTMB wants to leverage,
like the back office capabilities of an organization
like Ironman to scale what they've created into this series
which allows them to expand the scope.
And the good news is, you know, the silver lining in it
is that with that perhaps you expand
the exposure of the sport and bring more people into it.
Because it's all about growth. Right?
So Ironman will allow them to grow in a way
that they couldn't otherwise.
But if you're a traditionalist
you're thinking we don't need to grow, we've grown enough.
Like, let's keep what's great about it
and not allow it to be corrupted.
It's the old story, man.
We all liked the bands before they started playing
the arenas back in the club days.
Yeah.
I'm still like I am a mama guy,
back to mama, those Georgia days.
Bro, I saw fish in a gymnasium in Vermont.
Right. I know right?
Bro, you should have seen that show in the gymnasium.
It wasn't as good, but I like to think it was better.
Of course.
All right.
Let's take a quick break first to kind of round out
the the Iron Cowboy thing, please make a point
of following him at Iron Cowboy James on Instagram,
Instagram stories ,specifically to kind of follow
the moment to moment unfolding of his Epic journey.
And we'll be right back.
Okay. Before we go away.
What?
I have an idea to brand, since we're talking
about branding.
Should we partner with Ironman?
I've never done a WTC race ever.
I don't plan to either.
We might get calls from Ironman just for saying Ironman.
I'm afraid, Mont Blanc, you won't be able to say Mont Blanc,
does France know that Mont Blanc is owned by Ironman now.
I dunno, alert the lawyers. Right?
An interesting side note with that, you know how people
do Ironmans and then they get the Ironman tattoo,
like the m. tattoo.
Yes.
That's technically a copyright violation.
On their skin.
Exactly.
It's like a double violation.
Right, but of course it's the ultimate branding
for them as well.
So can you pick and choose which parts or which occasions
of that intellectual property transgression
you're going to police.
I think you should allow it.
If I was Ironman lawyers, I would allow the tattooing
but I would also demand to be able to literally brand them
with an Iron I, as they crossed the finish line.
That's a solution.
Wait, so the Brogan Graham film festival,
I'm gonna call it the hashtag FF or the three F's,
friendship, film, festival
Not the fire film festival with a Y?
The French Film festival.
Every time you do it.
Every time you send a film, a three F film.
Brought to you by three F's.
Right. Okay.
Trips F.
I don't follow.
I don't know. I'm just trying to brand it.
Just trying to brand it.
But the whole thing is it's not,
it's not for social media.
It's just an intimate exchange between two people.
That's true, we shouldn't try to brand these things.
Yeah, no.
See, this is a microcosmic example of the Ironman UTMB.
I'm part of the problem.
I'm coming from the dirt bag perspective.
Let's protect the purity of this art form.
Nothing is pure, Rich.
All right. We'll be back in a few.
We'll be back in a sec, but first, if you dig this podcast
and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book,
"Voicing change", featuring excerpts from poignant essays
by and glorious photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast.
It's a gorgeous, artful compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared there and all wrapped
in a hardcover coffee table form that provides a great taste
of what we do here at the RRP and serves as a beautiful
keepsake or gift for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available and we are shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
And we're back before we get into the main thing
I want to talk about today, that previous segment
that we just recorded, either that's art
or we just lost the whole audience.
Where do you fall on that?
Well, if it is art, we definitely lost the whole audience.
(both laughing)
Yeah, either way it's not good.
It's just two guys talking to each other.
Yeah, for the two people that have stuck with us now.
Welcome.
Yes, thank you for taking a risk, taking a chance on us.
So for the big story this week, rather than dive
into the news headlines, I wanted to seize an opportunity
to do something a little bit different,
which is riff off a tweet that I saw the other day
from my friend, Steve Magness.
Steve's a former friend of the pod and on the podcast twice,
coauthor with Brad Stulberg of a couple of great books.
He's an elite track and field coach, former Oregon
project coach, a guy who's been outspoken against doping
and Alberto Salazar specifically.
And he's just a source of wisdom on Twitter.
And he tweeted something that stuck with me
because it resonates with something I think about a lot.
And his tweet goes like this, "there's a reason
athletes have off seasons.
After intense stress, you need time to mentally
and physically recover.
Periodise your life.
No one has time to grind
and when you need to back off and recover.
I think it's a simple statement,
but I think it's also profound, this idea of periodizing,
not just your training, but also your life.
Like everything has a season.
And when I look at you, Adam, I see somebody who's trained
for hard things, who's done hard things.
But I'm not sure you've ever engaged in a proper
training protocol that involved periodization.
Maybe periodization has come up from time to time
in form of roll-ons, but are you familiar
with the concept of periodized training?
No.
You're not at all?
No?
I haven't, you say I've done hard things.
I mean, I haven't trained for like ultra distance events
or even, you know, like, I mean.
But periodization is a tried and true approach
to training for any.
It doesn't have to be an ultra distance thing.
If you're doing Olympic triathlons.
If you're training for a marathon,
if you're training for any kind of physical feat
or endurance challenge.
Periodization is a way of structuring how you create
your schedule going forward.
So let's say you have a year to prepare for a race,
a really big race, it's on the calendar.
You look at the end date and you're like, okay,
that day is coming,
Here I am 365 days beforehand.
How am I going to best prepare so that on that race day
I'm at my absolute peak to perform to my capabilities.
And the way you do that is you break down your training
into certain blocks.
You have this build phase and then you back off
and then you go a little bit harder
and then you back off again and then you increase again.
And then maybe you take two weeks of really easy training.
Like you build in periods of time mindfully
that allow your body to recover.
And this can happen quarterly, it can happen monthly.
It happens weekly. It happens daily.
So there's the macro and the micro that gets built
into all of this.
So that you are breaking your body down but not blind
to the fact that you've got to allow your body
to build itself back up so that you can then
approach your training as a stronger, fitter athlete
to take it, you know, to the next level.
To break through certain plateaus.
And knowing when to back off and how to back off
and for how long to back off is both an art and a science.
And I've had my best years as an athlete,
my best performances when I've really taken periodization
to heart and follow the direction of my coach, Chris South.
When I was a swimmer, there was no periodization,
we just went in and we hammered every single day.
And then we hung, you know, all our hopes
on a two week taper at the end of the season
and just prayed that it all worked out.
Sometimes it did. Sometimes it didn't.
But you were, that was early, earlier days.
This is like 80's.
That's what they did then.
Right, exactly.
It was all about...
But now, it's like understanding how hard you can push
before you tip into over-training and knowing
when to back off the gas and allowing your body to recover.
Knowing how long you need for your body to bounce back.
And what kind of training you're doing
during those sort of easier intervals of time
really becomes this incredible lever for growth
and performance breakthroughs.
So how would you, like if you're training for Catalina,
I'm most likely not doing the full distance Catalina
because I can't commit to the time it's gonna take to train
for it with a young one.
But I'm gonna do the sprint, which is 15 K.
So how would you periodize that?
Like when would you start and how would you periodize that?
First I would break up the period of time
into like three phases.
The first phase would be endurance building
like base-building period.
Where you're just working on your foundation
and you're getting a lot of zone to work in
and getting acclimated to spending a lot of time
swimming and running, so that your body
kind of knows what that feels like.
You're giving your tendons and your ligaments
the opportunity to adapt, not just your lungs
and your heart, but all of your muscles in your body
to figure out, like how to sustain itself
over long periods of time.
So that phase would be a slow progressive build
of going longer and longer and longer.
Mostly in the zone two phase.
But within that block, you're gonna do a little,
maybe like a two week build and then you're gonna have
four days that are gonna be pretty easy or maybe a week
that's pretty easy, where you're still training
but the gas isn't all the way pressed down, right?
You're backing off so that during that week of training,
you're allowing your body to recover and get stronger.
And then that would be followed by an another sub block
within the base building block of going a little bit longer
than you did in that initial block,
to push through to the next barrier.
And you just repeat, rinse and repeat, rinse and repeat
and pay attention to how your body is recovering
during those off periods so that you can better calibrate
what those rest weeks look like.
And then within each week you have a rest day, right?
So, and then within each day, you know, you have,
when are you training and what are you doing
in between your training sessions?
So periodization works at every level.
From yearly to monthly, to, you know, weekly to daily.
Then your second phase would be more of a strength
and speed building phase.
Where you're going to be doing more tempo work interspersed
with continuing to increase your volume over zone two.
But you're gonna choose moments where you're gonna have
really hard kind of zone three zone four, zone five efforts
in there to get used to the idea that your experience
when you're doing a swim run.
Which is that you're always changing gears.
You're ramping up your heart rate, it's coming back down,
it's going about, you're like, it's not like an Ironman
or a marathon where you get into,
you rev up to a certain speed and you hold it
as long as you can.
A small run, you're constantly switching back and forth.
So it would be more focused on getting your heart
and your lungs and your muscles acclimated
to heart rate spikes and getting fit enough
so that your heart rate comes back down
pretty expeditiously.
The third phase would be race specific,
then you're gonna start sort of training in the spirit
of what the race is and trying to mimic
what that experience is like.
You use six week blocks, usually?
Well, it depends on how much time you have,
you know what I mean?
Like you think, I mean, we could spend four hours
trying to figure out exactly what to do.
And this is an ideal situation.
This isn't necessarily, you know, the protocol
for the time crunched dad of a baby who only has, you know,
who's not going to be able to train every single day.
But basically I just wanted to lay that out
in the most general terms to help people understand
what periodization looks like.
Can we build in a period for me to hunch over my computer
and type with two fingers?
Yes, we can. There's room for all of it.
That's what I do between training sessions.
But I think the broader point here
and why I wanted to talk about this, you know,
given that I've learned a lot about the wisdom
of periodizing endurance training is that it's so applicable
in every other area of life.
And it goes back to ancient wisdom.
It's like eat with the seasons, live by the seasons.
Why do I feel so sluggish and tired in the colder,
darker months, because you're hard wired for that, right?
Like, so rather than...
Like how we are wired for when the sun went down,
we all slept for like that whole period of time
or like close to it and we've come so far from that.
So that there's so many kind of overlays.
Right, and now we're in this hustle porn culture
where if you're not, if your output isn't like insane
and you're not grinding 24/7, and staying up all night
and pulling all nighters and on your hustle,
there's something wrong with you.
Such that when you have a fallow moment and you want to rest
or you're like, I just don't have it today you feel guilty
or you beat yourself up or you have this sense
that you're falling behind.
And I think that sensibility, that mentality, that mindset
is anathema to long-term success.
I think we need to understand that we're all built
for periods of great productivity.
But if you want to sustain that over the long period
of time, you have to periodize that,
you have to periodize your career,
you have to periodize your creative output,
you have to periodize essentially everything that you do.
And the more mindful you can be to make sure
that you're incorporating fallow periods to coin
Bonnie Choi's article, which we're gonna talk about.
I think, you know, and it's,
for a lot of type A personalities it feels indulgent, right?
or selfish or unproductive to do that.
There's a guilt and there's a shame
that gets built into that.
That's driven by cultural pressures
that we need to overcome.
And as a 54 year old who's been doing stuff for a long time,
I could tell you, you can't just be cranking all the time.
Now, you as a content creator, you see burnout
amidst content creators, because they can't sustain
the level of output that they're doing.
And either flame out or disappear
or they have to reinvent themselves and create a way
of contributing their creativity in a manner
that's more sustainable with lifestyle.
It's interesting 'cause like two things came in my mind
when you told me you wanted to talk about this,
the first is when lonely planet travel guides
were my primary, you know, job, when I was doing that.
And it was a period from 2007 to 2013,
where I was gone eight, nine months a year.
And I would do like three of these guides
and that entailed long periods of travel,
usually in remote areas, not always, but usually.
And then come back either home or I'd rent a place
in the country and long periods of just, you know,
12 hour days, 10 hour days in the computer and then,
and living in situ, so I could make calls if I didn't have
all my research done, I knew where I was.
And so that has a built-in kind of, not fallow,
'cause you're still hustling, but there is periodization
in the research gathering and the writing.
And it felt natural.
And there is that still anytime you're on a story that like,
when you're trying to come up with something written
at the end of it versus what you're doing with a mics,
it's all one thing, but you're, you're reporting
but that's different than the writing.
Where you can analyze and be kind of create the distance
in between and organize it.
And you know what you want to say
versus the absorption which and the second thing
that came to mind was Bonnie's story which she published
in 2019, which I sent to you this morning.
And because that's what she's talking about
is creating that space for absorption as a creative person.
So that's immediately where my mind went.
It didn't go to athletics at all for me, because like,
athletics are just kind of like something
just to keep my mind right more than any than,
my body right.
But like, I don't think of it
in terms of any sort of outcomes or optimization.
But I immediately went to that point.
I was like, wow, I don't really have what I used to have.
There's no longer that period of like three months
where I'm just traveling and absorbing.
And three months of writing, like I don't have that anymore.
Two months of writing is what it used to be or a month.
So it's interesting.
And I did like that rhythm.
There's something real natural about it.
Yeah, it comes in phases, right?
Just like if you're making a movie,
you write the script by yourself or with a friend
or whatever, partner, then you shoot the movie,
then you edit the movie, then you market the movie.
All of those are part and parcel of being a filmmaker
but they're all very different disciplines
that I suspect for.
And, you know, every filmmaker is gonna excel
in different areas of those
and maybe doesn't like certain aspects of it.
But the switching gears aspect of it,
probably keeps them fresh, right?
In the same way that if you're a triathlete,
you get to switch up the different disciplines of sport
that you're pursuing.
For me people are always like,
which one do you like the best?
And it's like, I like that I get to change all the time.
And it's not the same thing every single day.
But I think on top of that is this idea of, you know,
to kind of harken to this idea of absorbing,
like that's where it gets tricky for people.
Like, look, a lot of people, they don't have the luxury
of like, I'm gonna kick back and absorb my life.
But if you're trying to express something,
if you're a creative person, you have to live your life
in order to have something to say,
you can't just be writing all the time.
Because you're gonna run out of things to write about
if you're not living, right?
Right.
So you have to live your life.
You have to have moments of absorption,
no matter what your career path or how busy
your circumstances may be.
What that looks like to you is gonna depend
on your circumstances and your, you know,
particularities of your life, of course.
But I think just being mindful of that
and trying to find ways, even within your day
in a given day to ruminate or do nothing
and not feel guilty about it, right?
Right.
There's that thing like stand-up comics
are people that just don't like to, you know,
like the people that don't like to wake up in the morning
you know, like are lazy, like become standup comics.
And it's like, what does that guy do?
He just does nothing.
He wakes up at noon and he like goes and gets a sandwich
and like wanders around.
And then does it's like, what is that person's, you know.
What's driving that person?
But they're overlooking the fact
that the brain is working all the time.
So there's observation, there's synthesis,
there's absorption.
All of those things are occurring
and we shouldn't be so quick to judge
how certain human operates.
Also, it's funny we say, he's doing nothing
or she's doing nothing, but they're being.
You know, it's almost like...
Right, but we're not allowed to just be
that's the broader point, right?
Right.
I mean there is a certain element of like, I think you get
to a certain point where you have to be able to afford
to be, but everyone has that.
Like I don't care what your job is.
There's going to be pressures too.
And we often fill that space of doing nothing
with absorbing other people's content.
Like most people I think absorb it through television
or Netflix or YouTube or whatever
and you know, myself included.
But you know, what Bonnie is talking about here
is kind of an active, not doing,
it's going to the park and people watching, it's reading,
she's not really advocating.
She's not really advocating vegging on the couch
and watching television.
No, no, no.
She's separating out the fallow, yeah.
Yeah, and acknowledging that in this age of distraction
that it's transgressive to do this, right?
There's one quote that I noted that I wanted to read
from the piece, which is called, "you're doing something
important when you aren't doing anything", we'll link it up
in the show notes, but she says, "protecting and practicing
fallow time is an act of resistance.
It can make us feel out of step with what the prevailing
culture tells us, the 24/7 hamster wheel of work,
the constant accessibility and the impatient press
of social media.
All hasten the anxiety over someone else's judgment.
If you aren't visibly producing you aren't worthy.
In this context taking time to lie dormant feels greedy,
even wasteful, and of course there are often
financial concerns."
So yeah, this notion that it's transgressive,
that it is an act of resistance that you have to push back
against culture and your addictive instinct to grab
the phone and ameliorate your, you know, your boredom
by filling it with scrolling or whatever it is
that you look out on your phone, it's very difficult.
It's never been more difficult to carve out that time,
that fallow time, time for rumination and quiethood.
And feeling wasteful.
I mean, yeah, that's exactly it.
Like, am I wasting time by doing X or Y or whatever.
And, you know, that's one thing that I think adventuring,
which is what I consider swimming and running these days
for me, it's like these mini adventures
that allows me to clear my head in a way,
that's a fallow time within a day for me.
But it's not though, because I'm still trying
to get something done.
So it really doesn't qualify as fallow time.
Yeah. It's hard.
I know.
And it's pushing my son and is like, dude,
tricycle is kind of fallow time.
But I also think it's the mindset that you bring
to whatever it is that you're doing, right?
Like you could go out and go for a walk with your son
and bring your phone and stare at your phone the whole time.
Or you leave your phone at home and you comport yourself
like Brogan and go up and talk to people
and live in your brain and, you know, kind of allow yourself
to mentally meander.
Yeah, which, you know,
we've been watching "Mad men" 'cause April never seen
"Mad men", so I'm rewatching the whole series.
We're in season six now.
And that's something, for all of Don Draper's many faults
although he is gifted too
One thing that we love about Don is his willingness to nap
at any time of day or night.
He is a world-class napper.
But when you're boozing that hard
I don't see any other way around it.
Like when you're hammering like four Manhattans at lunch,
a nap is in your immediate future.
And nobody loves a matinee more than Don Draper
on a workday.
That's true.
But that's exactly what he's doing though.
He calls that absorption.
He would be fully in on this.
Like the absorption state,
he didn't care when people worked.
You never see him in front of a whiteboard
mapping out his strategy for, you know, brand X.
He kind of comes up with his ideas sua sponte,
like very extemporaneously in the meeting.
Yeah, I am more like the Peggy Olsen, sweating it out.
Like trying to hammer at it.
Figure it out.
I'm not the Don Draper nappy matinee genius.
That's funny.
Does it hold up?
I bet it holds up pretty good. Right?
There was one episode where they had to do
a trigger warning though.
Really?
Yeah.
Even though it takes place in the 60's.
Which one?
It was when Roger sang in Blackface.
Oh.
And they did a trigger warning.
Roger, not that politically correct that guy.
Politically incorrect.
Well, you know, where they were early
in like the first season, it was 1960.
And they were all on Nixon side.
I remember that.
Yeah, I remember that, because they were considering
getting into the campaign marketing.
They wrapped Nixon, but Nixon wouldn't,
like the campaign wasn't listening to them.
(both laughing)
All right, I think we got off track here.
Did we cover the periodization of your life?
Tell me about your life.
Like periodizing, like where are you
in your periodization journey?
And what's the most successful you've ever been at it?
Well, one thing I've done is to build in this month
every year where I take off, which is new,
I've done it twice.
But I intend to do that every year.
I think travel for me is a big aspect of that,
in terms of rejuvenating me and exposing me
to new people and new places.
I find that to be very nourishing.
Like your big Island.
Yeah, when I went to Australia, but even, you know,
when pre-COVID there'd be speaking things
and I would get to go to all these cool places.
And for me, that like really reboots my system.
So COVID has been challenging just to be at home
and sit with my thoughts.
And I struggle with adopting the appropriate healthy mindset
around leveraging that appropriately.
But I think at the same time
we have to be gentle on ourselves.
Like, you know, not to kind of
beat a dead horse but it's been a really hard year
for everybody.
And I think a fallow year for everybody in a way
that we wouldn't have chosen or didn't expect.
That's true.
So being gentle on ourselves I think is part of that idea
of periodizing your life.
Like this was a fallow year, rather than live in regret
or frustration or resentment over it,
while we're still kind of in it.
Like how can we develop a better, healthier mindset
around this experience?
How can we learn from it?
How can we use it for that kind of internal journey
that will help improve our lives as we move forward
in other areas.
I miss the travel a lot, you know, especially lately.
And we were even thinking about jumping on a plane
here in May and trying to get like to Hawaii
for 10 days or something.
But are opting against it just to let this second wave
wherever it is kind of chill out.
And then we're third wave and then see where we're at.
But we're definitely feeling that it's, I mean,
travel is how we all reset in certain ways, adventure,
that kind of thing.
You kind of pull yourself out of who you are
and you can be in a totally different state of being
and then come back and it's the best way to go fallow.
I think it's the best way to observe.
But you can do that in our daily life here.
And we should all do more of that.
I think from the athletics perspective.
One thing that I think about
when you're talking about off seasons
is the great example of that is the current NBA season.
In that they had the shortest off season
in the history of the league.
Because they had to, if you remember
they had to move everything because of it,
and put it in a bubble in Orlando, you know,
to do the playoffs and everything else
after they'd shut down in March.
I think they moved, I forget when it was,
it was in the late summer.
I don't think it wrapped until like September or October.
I can't remember offhead, I think October.
And then the thought was usually the season starts again
like the end of October.
And so the thought was, they were probably not gonna start
again until after the new year.
But they actually launched
with something like less than three months off.
And I remember LeBron James being very outspoken about it
because he spends a million dollars a year on his body.
He's like, so he knows all about this.
Like he periodized to get peak for the playoffs.
And this NBA season has been one of the worst
in terms of major athletes coming down with injuries.
Yeah injuries.
And so it's interesting that, you know,
that's what I think about.
Like it does make a big difference
when you're in the elite level too, especially, right?
Yeah, a hundred percent.
But I think in terms of the everyday individual
thinking about the pandemic
and thinking about how to move forward.
So much of it is about acceptance too.
It's like when an athlete is injured and they're frustrated
that they can't train or they're falling behind
or what is this gonna mean in terms of the big race
that I'm training for?
There's nothing you can do about it, right?
So in this moment of repose, what can be learned?
How can you mine it to be better in other areas of your life
and use the various periods for what they're intended
to sort of avail you of?
I love it.
I don't know.
That's some good, classic, literal brain food.
All right, let's shift gears.
Spoken like a true hype man.
You job's secure.
Brogan is not moving to Los Angeles.
You're okay.
Your job is very secure.
My greatest ability is availability.
That's true.
Not to be underestimated, you know.
You have yet to say I can't.
There was one time where you couldn't
because you were having a baby.
Right, am I overly available?
No, you're appropriately available.
Appropriately available.
You don't want to be inappropriately available.
No. Cause then you're reeking of need.
Like don't you have anything else going on?
All right. Let's move on.
Yes.
We're gonna do a little, it's not really show and tell.
I'm just gonna note a few things.
I did want to say.
Let's tell.
You had to tell, no show.
To everybody who left a comment on the YouTube channel
and subscribed in response to the 10,000 distance kit
giveaway, thank you.
We reached out to five people, got addresses
and we'll be shipping those out shortly.
So you have that to look forward to.
We'll be doing more giveaways again.
I'm developing some new stuff with 10,000
and I'm pretty excited about, so I'll be sharing more
about that as the weeks and months unfold.
I wanted to give a shout out to friends of the pod,
Jesse Thomas, Lauren Fleshman, Gabby Reese,
and Laird Hamilton.
They formed this super twins activate alliance
between Picky Bars and Laird Superfood,
which I think is super food cool.
It's the first time two husband and wife teams,
all four of them have been on the podcast
and went off and merge their companies.
So I feel emotionally attached to this in an illogical way.
So the companies have merged?
I don't know if it's a part or if it was an...
I don't know if Laird Superfood acquired Picky Bars.
It's some kind of alliance, some form of merger.
I don't know the specifics of the business points
on how it all worked out.
But happy for all involved.
I'm a believer in the Laird, that coconut creamer
for the powdered coffee, I used to bring that on the road,
on work trips.
Yeah, I got some of that in the mail the other day.
So thanks to all of them personally.
I'll bring it into the studio,
products by Picky Bars and Laird Superfood.
Beautiful.
Should we talk about this QAnon into the storm documentary
that we both watched?
You know, we should talk about it just because you and I
love to talk about it.
We love talking about QAnon
and we've been talking about it forever.
Yes.
And this documentary kind of came and went.
We both watched it.
It never felt like the appropriate time to discuss it.
I don't want to belabor it too long,
but I thought it was worth noting if people haven't seen it,
it's on HBO Max right now.
How many episodes is it? Four or five? Something like that.
I think it's six.
Yeah.
Let me check.
It's a pretty interesting docu series,
written and directed by this guy, Colin Hoback.
That goes into not so much the implications
of the QAnon movement, but really the people behind it.
For those that have been living under a rock
and don't know what QAnon is.
QAnon is the far right conspiracy theory,
alleging that a secret cabal of Satan worshiping
cannibalistic pedophiles is running a global child,
sex trafficking ring and plotted against
former US president, Donald Trump while he was in office.
Cue drops cryptic, what would you call them? Missives?
Yes.
On 8chan, which is this horrible website.
Started on 4chan, moved to 8chan.
Moved to 8chan, 8chan notable for not just QAnon
but kind of being the message board for Gamergate
and Pizza gate.
In this docu series, Colin goes to visit the people
behind 8chan, which was this website
started by this guy, Fred Brennan, created 8chan,
who, what is the nature of his disorder?
He's in a wheelchair.
He was born with like some sort of brittle bone syndrome.
It's a congenital.
A congenital, so he couldn't develop right,
he couldn't like go out and play.
And he was confined to, kind of like a Mr. Glass,
like in that movie but it also involves
some sort of malformations of his limbs.
And so he basically, the way for him to become
a full blooded person, which he talks about on Rabbit Hole
and he's talks about even more so in this,
is to have this online presence.
He was able to be like a top dog online.
Right. Yeah.
It became his real life,
essentially it was being lived online.
And he really understands the internet
in a very profound way.
He creates 8chan, grows 8chan to a certain point
and then basically is, I guess, verging on bankruptcy
or just...
There was a moment where the traffic was too much
and he didn't have the resources to be able to like,
to keep it up.
And that's how he partnered with these guys.
Yeah, so he ends up hooking up with this guy, Ron Watkins
and his son, Jim Watkins, who are...
No, Jim's the father.
Oh, Jim's the father.
Yeah, Jim Watkins, Jim ends up actually acquiring 8chan
from Fred, Fred relocates to Manila
where Ron and Jim are operating.
And through the docu series, you get a glimpse into kind of
the back-office of 8chan.
And it's rather illuminating and disturbing to actually see
how the sausage is made with this whole bag.
You kind of hint like, going into the series
I didn't know if I had to watch it
because I listened to Rabbit Hole.
And Rabbit Hole was so good at kind of like implying
that the Watkins most likely had something to be,
like even if they weren't cute, they knew who it was
but you kind of thought it was one of them.
Not originally, but they co-opted like, we'll get into that.
But I always kind of was suspicious of those two people,
the father and son and Manila.
They're American, by the way.
And, you know, but going into seeing the way Colin
put it together and how he won the trust of these people
who probably didn't want to be on camera,
like going into this.
He wins their trust.
He's there for all these seminal moments
and he pieces together.
It's really brilliant and I think completely revealing
about this father and son megalomania,
kind of like internet company that just,
I mean, I still can't wrap my head around the motive.
Well, Hoback is a fly on the wall.
Like he never passes judgment on these subjects
throughout the movie.
So on some level he's engendered their trust.
And who knows what he told them about the purpose
of this film that he was making.
We don't know, but on some level
they're all very comfortable having him around
to document this and essentially...
For months and months.
It's like a true crime story.
Like he's trying to solve the riddle of who is QAnon.
And along the way he interviews a lot of these
QAnon YouTube people and pundits, et cetera.
And ultimately, you know, lands on, it culminates with
what I guess you could characterize as almost an admission
by Ron Watkins that he is perhaps Q.
Yes, but we should set this up because Jim Watkins,
who runs the internet business out of Manila,
his son, Ron, who lives..
This is shitty office and it's just gross.
It's just one of those high-rises, it's like...
All this is coming from here?
Right, and he owns a pig, he's a Yogi.
A self-proclaimed yogi that owns a pig farm
and a health food store with their own bacon line.
This is legit.
And he's a big fan of fancy washes and fancy pens
and changing his facial hair.
Yes and then obviously it's implied,
but he doesn't get into it.
But father and son do like to like frequent,
well the son frequents like some sort of a massage parlor
in Sapporo Japan.
Well, it's unclear why Ron, the son, finds himself
in all different parts of the world throughout.
They never really explained that.
Like is he fleeing from the law?
Like what's exactly going on?
And Jim, meanwhile, the dad is constantly saying
that he doesn't care about politics,
that he's not interested in politics,
that he doesn't really follow Qanon.
But fully right wing.
Yeah, because his actions belie his words.
And at some point, Jim comes back to United States
which is why, and he has to sell the pig farm,
they don't really explain why.
And Ron, like was he working in intelligence?
They hinted maybe he worked in intelligence.
He was called monkey on Twitter, Ron Watkins.
And at one point he became like, I think Donald Trump
shared a couple of his tweets.
Right, at one point,
Ron talks about how there's a Republican operative
who's really figured out
how to accelerate growth on Twitter.
Like some kind of algorithmic solution
that allows extreme stickiness and virality
on that platform.
And at some point, Ron hires this guy or enlist him
to get his code monkey account on Twitter to blow up,
which it does.
And he ends up with like, I don't know,
700,000 or 500,000 followers or something like that.
And then Trump is retweeting him.
And this is in the latter stages of QAnon and 8chan.
I think it was the vice versa,
that the Republican operative wanted to hype up code monkey
because he was pro Q, he wanted the Q stuff out there.
Right? 'cause it was beneficial to the Republican candidates
or something like that.
Or I don't know.
But there was code monkey's personal account
that came a little bit later when he became outspoken.
And the way that he used language on Twitter as code monkey,
they track that against the vernacular used by QAnon.
And they kind of graph it to demonstrate
that there's a good chance that these are the same people.
And I think that the short version is, someone else
was originally QAnon, we don't really know who that was.
They were on 4chan, it got moved to 8chan.
And at some point QAnon started to write differently.
And that's when they think he had just disappeared.
And Ron and Jim, or maybe just Ron took it over
to keep it going because it was the primary driver
of traffic to their web business.
But there was no real, they never really implied
like what the motive was because they claim 8chan
is a money loser.
And then like, what would be, was it a game?
Was he like, was it like,
just like this real life role-playing game for Ron?
I think there is revelry and chaos with these guys.
Like they're getting off on just wreaking havoc
and whatever, you know, Jim would say about his disinterest
in politics, he keeps popping up.
He at some point has to go hire this first amendment lawyer
in Washington and he's elated to be able to be, you know,
a rabble rouser in a congressional hearing at one point.
And then Hoback is present with Jim
at the Capitol insurrection.
And there's all this crazy footage there's also footage
of the Qanon showing, like early footage of him
at these other get-togethers, these conferences
where you see this guy.
I think it was in like a council meeting or something.
And he comes in.
So it's fascinating for that alone.
And meanwhile, Fred Brennan, who created 8chan,
starts to distance himself from the whole thing
and becomes kind of a voice, a contrarian voice
calling Ron and Jim to the mat on their behavior
and sets about trying to get 8chan,
which later becomes 8kun dismantled.
Yeah, and we don't want to get into all the spoilers
because watching Fred's journey is actually riveting.
And to me like there was so much great footage
that kind of like, he connects this up
to like all the way back, early internet kind of stories.
Like every episode, I'd say critically the first episode,
if you watch the first episode and feel disjointed
and kind of your head spinning.
I felt like the first episode was weak
and that it covered tried to cover too much.
And it was like way disjointed.
But the subsequent episodes I think are really well-crafted.
He has this, when it talks about free speech,
he pulls up the KKK march in Illinois in the 70's
that the ACLU sued to allow to happen.
Because it was, you know,
the idea was get speech out there in public.
I thought that was an interesting story.
The Skokie Nazis.
Yeah, Skokie Nazis.
And then the heaviest footage to me was not, you know,
they used the new Yorker footage with the capital riot.
But to me the heaviest footage was the Christ church killer.
The guy that went and shot people in a mosque,
I think 30 or something, I forget how many died completely,
it's like 30 or 40.
And you see him, remember he live streamed this.
This was something that was live streamed
and it was on 8chan, people were watching, Facebook.
Yeah, no, the Christ church killer.
Oh, the killing was live streamed.
But then it was hosted on 8chan.
It was on Facebook where he was live streaming
and 8chan was, the comments were on 8chan,
where people were watching it and commenting.
And you don't see, there's a little bit of blood.
You see all the way up when he's driving,
like as if he's just whistling, driving to work.
It's the sketchiest, it's the scariest moment
I think I've...
And I've seen some crazy stuff that is out there,
like of these crimes that we've all heard of.
I've never seen anything that was as chilling as that to me.
Yeah.
It's, it's horrific, it's horrific.
And then to hear Ron and Jim, you know,
refuse to accept any responsibility for proliferating,
this kind of...
But that's what happened.
That was the idea of 8chan.
That's why it has to be called 8kun now.
Because at that point that was it.
Like once that happened and then right after that
was the synagogue shooting in San Diego,
and that was the end of 8chan.
Right?
Yeah.
So it would have been nice if the series delved
a little bit more deeply into the implications
of all of this.
It really is just a story of following these guys around
and trying to understand why they were doing
what they were doing.
Being these, you know, chaos agents.
And we don't really get answers to that.
No, it's just an offbeat tech story
but with real world implications.
And unfortunately think why, what you're getting at
the unsatisfying conclusion is really just that they wanted
to fuck with everybody.
And like, we all had to live through it.
And that's really, you know, a difficult nihilistic pill
to swallow at the end of the day
after everything that's happened.
It was like there's no, you know,
it wasn't motivated by ideology.
Or money.
They didn't get paid.
Yeah, none of them were making any,
they're losing money on this whole thing.
Right.
So what was the purpose?
Like it was purposeless entertainment for a few people
and torture for everybody else.
Yeah.
All right, enough said on that.
But you should watch it.
Yeah, you should check it out.
It's on HBO Max, QAnon into the storm.
What else you got for me?
I have something to show.
This is the new Rachel Cushner collection.
"The Hard Crowd", it's essays from 2000 to 2020.
Rachel Cushner is one of my three favorite writers
currently working along with Michael Chavon
and Colson Whitehead, who are obviously
both Pulitzer prize winners.
Cushner has previous novels, "Flame Throwers",
which is a spectacular book about 1970s motorcycles
and the art scene in New York and socialist uprising
in Italy in the 70's.
"Telex from Cuba" is about kind of this mining town,
company town in Cuba, American owned,
right before the Cuban revolution,
which is a spectacular read.
And "Mars Room" is about a women's prison, but this book
kind of includes essays that inform all those novels.
So if you've seen, well, not "Telex from Cuba" so much,
but "Flame Throwers" and "Mars Room".
And it includes like a look back at what San Francisco
used to be, pre tech, and some really great stories
about the old hunts, where the bands played
and where she used to bartend.
And she herself is great with cars
and is a motorcycle rider.
And at the time, she actually participated
in an illegal race down Baja from Tijuana
all the way to Cabo, illegal on highway one.
And she wiped out going over a hundred miles an hour
at one point, which is a scene that is kind of used
in "Flame Throwers" also in a different way.
But like she's an incredible motorcycle rider too
or she was in her early days.
And just a remarkable read.
There's, you know, given the news of today,
which is you know, Israeli police, you know,
invading East Jerusalem and fighting with Palestinians.
There's a story in here about Palestinians
living in East Jerusalem and that's riveting
and very sad and there's essays on, you know,
Marguerite Darius and motorcycles and San Francisco.
And so I just thought, if you haven't heard of her
and you are interested in the non-fiction stuff,
this is the one, otherwise pick up "Flame Throwers"
or "Telex from Cuba", you should get to know Rachel Cushner.
That's cool.
"The Hard Crowd", did that just come out?
Just came out, got a great review on the New York times
from Dwight Garner.
But to me, when she's at her best, she's electric.
Like just electric.
It's very highbrow.
It is a little highbrow.
She writes about art, she writes about literature
and she writes about hardcore motorcycles.
Yeah. All right, man, I'll check it out.
I've never read her work so I'll prefer to start with that.
Let's introduce her to the RRP crowd.
I think we just did.
Right. Which is a different kind of hard crowd.
You're more of a soft crowd.
A little bit, for the three people that are still with us.
My little share of the week of fines
that I've been enjoying is perhaps a little bit
more low brow, but also kind of high brow.
I've been enjoying this television series
called "Le Bureau".
(Adam laughing)
It's quite possibly one of the best things
I've ever seen on television.
It's extraordinary.
It's the third version of the office, right?
Well, Le Bureau means the office.
I think the full title is like "Le Bureau de Legend",
of legends, the office of legends.
But it's essentially, it's five seasons long.
It's a French series that Chronicles life
in the DGSA, which is basically their CIA.
But it's as if you were watching,
it's like if you were watching a Bourne movie,
but everything transpires in the office and you never,
like there's no action.
There's no fights.
There's no, almost all of it is about trade craft.
But trade craft in terms of how people kind of navigate
and communicate in the bartering world of intelligence.
So the legend are the legends, are the agents who adopt
these alternative identities and then go out into the world
sourcing information, like infiltrating,
primarily middle Eastern countries
and the experiences that they have.
And it all centers around a love story.
Because in season one, the main character who's played
by Matthew Kassovitz, who you might know from "Amelie".
He plays this undercover agent who is dispatched to Syria
for six years.
He falls in love with a Syrian professor
and he has to return to France, like his tenure is up,
and in the first scene he basically lies to her
and he loses her.
And for the next five seasons it's this journey
of trying to get back to her
and all this crazy stuff happens.
But what's beautiful about it, it's very French.
There's a lot of sort of existential voiceover.
Is it drama or comedy?
It's drama.
Oh, no, it's not comedy at all, It's very serious.
But it's also, it has lighthearted moments.
And I think what's really unique about it is the manner
in which, it's something you don't see
in American television, where it really takes its time.
It's on a very slow boil.
And it's really not about the action.
It's about the relationship between all of these people
that work together in the DGSA
and these characters that you really just fall in love with.
So it's a beautifully wrought story.
It's extraordinarily rendered with extreme precision.
And I can't recommend it enough.
Like I did not want it to end.
And it's one of those experiences where I'm a season
and a half in and I'm just delighted
that there's five seasons.
And I get to just immerse myself
in the world of these characters.
It's subtitled, so it's a little bit of work
to have to deal with that.
That's highbrow.
But honestly like it was absolutely delightful
and wonderful.
So I can't recommend it enough.
I think it's on AMC,
which you can access through Amazon or Apple TV.
Can I ask you something about TV series?
Sure.
Do you feel like when a series is starting to lose itself,
like after like the first, I'm not talking about this one,
but like, you know, series like they get a little long
and then they're not as good as they used to be.
Do you stick with it to the end?
Or do you get out early?
It depends, I've gotten better at getting out early,
because there's so much.
You got to get out, right?
There's so much good stuff.
I don't have time for something
that isn't really completely engrossing.
I'm not going down with this ship.
I don't have tolerance, like if I start to lose it,
like, I'll give it a chance
because sometimes it takes a while.
Right?
So I'm not going to bail prematurely.
I'll give it enough time so that I can make
an informed decision about how much investment
I'm gonna make in this.
But if it's not doing it for me, I'm out.
And the other thing I have no tolerance for anymore
is the idea that you're going to drip episodes
out of a show week by week.
Like, come on guys, we're past that.
Drop the whole season or get out of town.
Like, I don't understand this hanging on to this model
of we're going to hold back.
Drop the whole season or get out of the business.
It's something that I think is going to be great,
I will wait until the whole season is out
before I even begin.
Because I don't wanna get a couple of episodes in
and then have to wait.
HBO is one of the worst offenders.
They're terrible.
Netflix understands this
Netflix does understand it.
But interesting, I always, if you've entertained me,
I'll give you some rope but I will get out early.
I'm not afraid to cut the ties on.
And, you know what, with books too,
I'm not afraid to cut the ties if I have to.
Yeah. I think it's harder with books 'cause you're like,
oh, this book and it's here and I have to finish it,
you know, and it's like, no you don't.
But this book I've read cover to cover.
Good.
Yes.
You're a strong man, sir. Adam Skolnick, content creator.
All right, Rachel Kushner, content creator.
What are we doing with this podcast episode?
We're all over the place.
Talking about all kinds of, I don't know.
Is this working for you guys,
for the people out there in the world?
Let us know.
All right, we got a couple cool wins of the week.
Let's bring it back.
All right, this winner of the week,
I'm gonna set up for you.
This is right in your wheelhouse.
This is shock waves in the food world great.
This is Jeff Gordaneer and you had to talk about it.
Gordaneer.
Well, this is a massive story in the food world.
Basically Daniel Humm, who's the proprietor chef
of 11 Madison Park, which is arguably the premier restaurant
in New York city.
I think it has four Michelin stars, which is extraordinary,
had to close down during the pandemic like all restaurants
and just announced the other week
that it was going to reopen
as a 100% plant-based restaurant.
Which is truly a landmark extraordinary decision.
Of the 132 restaurants worldwide with three Michelin stars,
not one is vegan.
So he's making a very bold statement.
I mean, this is the culinary world at its most elite,
like to eat at this restaurant is unbelievably expensive.
$335 tasting menu.
Exactly, and I think if you're going as a couple
you're not getting out of there
for like less than a thousand dollars.
It's like crazy expensive.
But this is the very apex, pinnacle of fine dining.
And for him to say, we're gonna toss out that menu
and we're gonna do it a hundred percent plant-based,
I mean, it was trending on Twitter,
there was a million articles in New York times, Eater,
everybody was covering this.
Lots of opinions, plenty of poo-poos and naysayers,
you know, saying it's not gonna work,
but I couldn't be more excited about this.
I think it's really cool.
Jeff Gordaneer immediately texted me and says, he's like,
he's covered Danielle for Esquire.
So he knows him and he...
You're looking into that story, right?
It's an incredible profile, the Esquire profile.
Right. Yeah.
So Jeff's profile is called Daniel Humm,
is the greatest chef in America and possibly the world.
Like that's what we're talking about here.
An amazing profile by Jeff who's obviously a wonderful,
beautiful writer.
But Jeff gave me his email address and he's like,
you got to get in touch with them right away.
Like this is hot.
So I emailed, I cold emailed Daniel Humm,
expecting like there's a 10% chance
this guy's gonna get back to me
in the middle of this media firestorm.
But he got right back to me and he's like, yeah,
I want to do the podcast
but I want you to eat at the restaurant first.
So I'm like, adventure here we come.
Yeah, that's right.
I go to New York.
I want to eat at this restaurant.
I want to get them on the podcast.
I want to hear the whole story.
So we're looking at when we can schedule that.
But hopefully that will happen
in the not too distant future.
I probably won't be able to go there until like July.
But...
I'm available.
You want to come?
Yeah, I'm available.
All right. I'll let you know.
I thought you said you shouldn't be overly available.
What's the appropriate amount of availability?
You can't complain about not getting sleep
and having a baby and can't train
and then suddenly be available to go to New York city
at the drop of a hat.
But we'll talk about it. We'll see.
We'll see how this episode goes.
You guys, I'm not sure I'm invited.
I'll just dangle it.
We'll see.
What's also cool about Daniel is that this guy
was almost a pro cyclist, like a very accomplished cyclist.
He was looking at a pro career, he could have gone pro,
that was available to him, I believe.
But he made a decision.
He recognized like listen, I'm never going to be
at the highest level of this.
And he started pursuing an alternative career path.
It's like one of those people great at a lot of things.
Isn't he a three hour marathoner?
He's a very good marathon runner, and I believe in 2008,
he ran 251 in the New York marathon.
I don't know if he runs it every year.
He's run it a bunch of times 312,
I think he ran 310 in 2018.
So marathon runner, almost pro cyclist,
obviously very fit athletic guy who has been eating,
predominantly vegetarian for many years I believe
at this point and has been thinking about
making this transition in the food world
with his restaurant.
In cognizance of not just the way the world is moving,
but his responsibility as somebody who is, you know,
very prominent in this world.
And I think it's ballsy to do that.
And I wish I'm only the best
and I can't wait to enjoy his food
and meet him and get him on the podcast.
In researching this little story I came across this gem
like that, and I think New York times, one of their stories
talked about Anne Kim, the chef in Minneapolis
has Suki and Mimi have like a highly rated,
I think a starred, maybe not a star but like a highly rated
vegan menu or vegan restaurant.
Did you hear about that?
I didn't, and since I was just in Minneapolis,
now I'm bummed.
Brogan?
I didn't know about that.
Yeah, Brogan, maybe he can go do a little recon.
Brogan And Jeff, it's probably Jeff Gordaneer
might've covered this restaurant.
Maybe it was in that next story,
I pulled that from somewhere.
But, you know, what Humm is doing
isn't totally unprecedented.
A couple of restaurants have tried this,
perhaps most notably L'Arpege in Paris,
which I had the great opportunity of experiencing.
Julie took me there for my birthday,
several years ago.
The chef there, Olam Pissarro,
he's called the vegetable whisperer.
He stopped serving meat in his restaurant in 2001.
And, you know, from what I understand,
L'Arpege has only become more prominent.
It's quite the place.
And it's one of those places where it's just like
serving after, you know, it's like a million dishes
and you're there for like five hours.
And every plate is like a little thing
but, you know, extraordinary.
This is like, I think the context of this Epicurious
is not having any more meat or like there's no beef anymore
on any of their recipes.
They're not putting publishing any more beef recipes
because of climate change.
Like this does seem to be a movement that's kind of creeping
towards something significant.
I mean, already it's significant
when you have Daniel's restaurant going, you know,
11 Madison going completely vegan or vegetable veggie.
Not completely vegan,
they're doing honey and milk for coffee.
But other than that, completely plant-based.
I think that's the only non plant-based menu items.
But he hasn't revealed the actual menu yet.
Yeah, but like it is a major thing
when you're talking about if there's a contest.
Symbolically it's massive.
Yeah. Yeah. Very exciting.
So that's the kind of high brow,
like food at the highest level of the culinary universe.
But I want to take it back down to boots on the ground
and remind people that this quest that we're on
to introduce the plant-based lifestyle to as many people
as possible is only gonna get so far unless we redress
the problem of food deserts and access in urban communities
to healthy plant-based foods, right?
Like it's one thing to, you know, I'm gonna go
to 11 Madison Park and drop major coin on this crazy meal,
but what about the average everyday person who's living in..
East New York?
Yeah, exactly.
And there aren't even grocery stores.
Let alone any kind of healthy plant-based options.
Which brings me to the next thing I wanted to share,
which is my friend, Nil Zacharias, has founded
this new company.
He's a CEO of a new venture called Plantega.
You can check it out online at Eat Plantega.
And essentially the idea, I love this it's brilliant,
is creating these basically kiosks, like refrigerated kiosks
that are stocked with healthy plant-based foods
that they're placing in bodegas.
They've started in New York.
I don't know how many locations they have right now.
But in bodegas, across New York city,
they're adding these refrigerated kiosks
that are just stocked with all kinds of healthy stuff.
So that they're expanding the availability of healthy,
affordable options into these food desert neighborhoods.
And some Bodegas have like a grill oriented
and they also have like a grill option
or something like that.
For some takeaway stuff.
Oh, was there a grill?
Maybe it's kind of like Starbucks
where you pull it out of the fridge
and they'll grill it up there in the bodega.
But my understanding is that it's pre-prepared
like sandwiches and salads and things like that.
Fantastic.
And this is just out of the gate, it's brand new.
But certainly an idea we're celebrating.
And I think it could go a long way towards really addressing
this problem of healthy food access
in underprivileged communities.
So good on you Nil and let me know how I can support
this mission and what you guys are trying to achieve.
And, you know, I just made a brunch,
a mother's day brunch with beyond meat, breakfast, sausage,
miyoko's butter and just eggs.
What do you want a medal?
No, I'm just saying?
Those are the three on here that I read.
Yeah, they partner with miyoko's beyond and just.
Miyoko's it's fabulous. Yeah.
So cool.
Cool.
Awesome. Should we go to some listener questions?
I would love that.
Do it, Is it time to do that?
It is time.
Okay.
What do you think would happen
if we went to a daily show?
You and me daily?
Daily.
I'm available.
(both laughing)
Wait, that would have been good on.
Wait, is that on?
Is this thing on?
All right. Are we ready?
Okay, here we go.
Greg from Virginia.
Hey Rich.
My question is about the topic of money.
As a child, I was taught that money is a variable
that has a significant influence on our choices.
How are you gonna pay for it?
was my parents' first question
when I would talk about my dreams.
In "Finding Ultra" Rich, you share a moment
when you had left your law practice,
was waiting to get traction as an author
and was on the brink of financial ruin.
How were you able to maintain the pursuit of your dream
and resist the urge to return to your law practice
exclusively just to provide for your family?
How would you advise others to think about money,
especially if it creates an obstacles to making change?
I want to thank you guys very much for your valuable insight
and your podcast, and especially this particular format.
This interactive format makes it much easier
and much better to be able to interact.
Have you guys have a great day, bye.
Thanks Greg.
That's a great question.
I think it's an important question.
No doubt.
I want to preface what I'm gonna say,
by saying that I am not telling anyone what to do
or not to do, nor am I giving any financial advice
but I will share a little bit of my experience.
And I think first of all, I'm with you,
I grew up in the same way,
being told, you know, when I would give voice to anything
aspirational or inspiration, you know,
sort of aspirational for my life being brought back
down to earth with a heavy dose of kind of prudent reality.
So I'm on your wavelength, Greg.
But what I've come to think, the way I've come to think
about this is as, when I think about money as this balance
or this dance between responsibility or prudence
on the one hand and on the other hand,
understanding that money is just energy.
You know, money is of course a variable
that is going to influence choice.
But the key, I think first and foremost is understanding
that we don't live in a zero sum game.
And that by adopting a mindset of universal abundance
will help you really get that money
just like everything else is this wave form, this energy.
Something that in my experience tends to be less important
and flow a little bit more freely
when your life is oriented, not around the pursuit of it
but rather the pursuit of purpose.
It is true that, you know, I grew up with parents
who were hammering a similar message into me
and I oriented my life around that perspective.
And I found that in so doing,
it didn't matter how much money I made.
I never had any of it because I was so out of alignment
with a greater sense of purpose that I would compensate
for that lack of fulfillment by spending whatever I had
to kind of fill that hole.
So I was chasing the dragon in a way
that I was never going to get on top of it.
And it was only by kind of crashing into a wall
with all of that and flaming out that I was able
to reconfigure my relationship to money and I did do it
through an extended period of hardship
where we didn't have any.
And that forced me to get really clear on what my needs were
and what was most important to me and what my values were.
And I made a commitment to pursue those values,
irrespective of any kind of financial reward.
And I will say there were plenty of moments
where my faith was tested and if Julie had not had my back
I very well would have scampered back and tried to get a job
that would pay the bills because it was very difficult.
It was emasculating, at times very humiliating.
Didn't you even have to take some,
like small kind of law gigs at one point
when things weren't going well.
Well, I did, I was sort of practicing law
as I was writing, "Finding Ultra",
but when that book came out I was like, I'm not doing,
I drew a line in the sand and I was like,
I'm not doing it anymore.
I'm trusting that this is going to open up the door
to a new path.
And it took a long time.
You know, the phone just didn't rang for a long time.
There were months where we were scrambling
like nobody's business and having cars repossessed
and having our trash bins taken away.
Being unable to, you know, figure out
how we were gonna feed the kids that night.
It was really, really difficult.
My faith was tremendously tested, Julie, you know,
I look back on it and I don't know how she had the fortitude
to like have my back in that period of time, but she did.
And she would constantly hammer home this idea of like,
the only way out is forward.
Like you can't go backwards.
Like you've come too far, the answers you seek
are ahead of you and I'm with you and we're together
and we'll figure it out.
And money comes and money goes but what's important here
is you finding your voice and figuring out, you know,
how you're gonna move forward in the world.
And that's like a precious gift.
And you know, I'm here to help you honor that.
And that takes an extraordinary human being.
It does.
It really does that.
Not the average person.
It's not like, behind every great man
there's a great woman.
Like no, she was like the Jedi, while I was like panicking
in the corner, you know?
And so without her, none of this happens.
But I think because we went without, for such a long period
of time and we were compelled to like live in the moment
and it really did reframe my relationship with money.
And these decisions that I made about how I wanted
to live my life were decoupled
from any pursuit of financial gain.
Like I made that bow down.
I was like, I don't care.
This is the way I want to go. This is what makes me happy.
This is what's fulfilling.
This is where I see promise and opportunity,
even if I don't see it right now.
And it didn't have anything to do
with financial remuneration.
So you remove that completely from the equation.
By like removing that, in some weird spiritual equation,
I created space for it to come in in a different way.
And by continuing to trust my instincts
and follow my curiosity and double down on these values
as kind of the foundation or the architecture
for what I do professionally, I'm suddenly,
you know, it's ridiculous.
But like, I make way more money now than I ever,
I never thought I would ever have money.
Like I just made peace with that.
I will never have money, that's fine.
And now I've got all this money.
Like technically I'm like rich, which is fucking crazy.
You're rich times two.
I don't think about it.
I don't think about how much money is coming in,
my spending habits haven't really changed.
I don't really do anything differently.
Like my whole relationship with money is different.
Like I just hold it loosely.
And so I don't know how that's instructive to somebody else.
Other than to say that if I've discovered anything
through this journey it's that the key is figuring out
what gets you excited in the morning.
And with that, you have this opportunity
and this responsibility to get clear
on how to orient, like purpose premised on those values
and whatever it is that is lighting you up,
the more that you continue to do it,
the universe starts to orient around you.
Like it congeals around you to provide opportunities.
And I think over time, those opportunities lead to some kind
of vocational situation that will allow you
to meet your needs.
I'm not saying you're going to get rich
or anything like that, but you will find yourself
in a situation where work doesn't feel like work.
Because it's something that you would be doing anyway.
Does that make sense?
It does.
I think it's great.
And I think Jedi Julie deserves to be an action figure.
She does.
We know people who make action figures.
Yeah.
She'd be good.
Yeah, I think the other thing too is,
you know on that note of here's my dream,
well, how are you going to pay for it?
All I can tell you is that every dream that I've realized,
I couldn't pay for.
If I set out at the beginning to say, well,
I have this thing, how am I going to pay for it?
I never would've gotten out of the gate.
The thing is you have to just start pursuing it.
And like I said, the universe arranges itself
around you to provide the support that you need.
It might not look like what you would like it to look like.
And it might not be as much as you would like it to be.
But generally it allows you to take one more forward step.
Like, that's it.
You don't get the blueprint.
You don't get to see where this is leading
or how it's all going to play out.
You just don't get to see the whole picture.
All you get on the daily is a test.
Can you take that next step?
Your faith is tested.
And I think every time you show up to pass that test
there's something that happens in the universe
where it says, okay, he passed that test.
We'll give them a little, throw them a little loose change.
See if he can pass the next test.
And also the conversations around you, including from
if your parents are around and still not just in your head,
but in your life.
Those conversations start to change too.
But it could take many years, could take five years,
could take 10 years.
But the conversations, all of a sudden you'll notice one day
and it won't be about, you know, can he do it
or you should get a job or blah, blah, blah.
It'll be, you know, conversations about pride.
Like, you know.
Right, because when you're in it, you cannot expect
the support of people like that.
They're just not going to,
like everybody thought I was insane.
People were telling Julie like, what's the matter with you?
You got to divorce this guy.
Like he's completely lost it.
So that's the way that it is when you're in the midst of it.
And that makes it even harder to find your footing
because you start to question yourself,
like maybe I am insane.
Everybody else thinks I'm insane.
Of course, when it all works out, then it's like,
oh, we're so proud of you.
And we saw it all the time and we supported you.
They forget that they were the one saying,
how are you going to pay for that thing in the beginning.
And that's just the way that it's wired.
That's the way it goes.
And it's not for everybody.
Like, it was really hard.
Like I'm not wishing this journey on people.
Not everybody is cut out for it.
If you're happy in your job and you have a profession
and your goal is to provide for your family
and have barbecues on the weekends.
That's great.
I'm not telling people to quit their job.
I'm speaking to the person who's got that yearning
in their soul where they feel like they just can't do it
one more day and they have this sense or this calling
that there's something out there.
And all I'm saying is, listen to that, pay attention to it.
Try to put a little wind in that sail.
You know, put a little fertilizer in that soil
and be open to where it might lead you and pay attention.
You're talking to Greg from Virginia.
That's right.
Thanks for the question, Greg.
Now we're going to go to the great North.
Hi, Adam and Rich.
This is John calling from the North of England.
So I learned to swim three years ago,
and this summer I'm doing a swim run that has lakes
and trail running, and it has a lake crossing in it.
I don't have any access to lakes to train in
because they've become too polluted in my neck of the woods.
But I do have access to the sea and obviously
it can be really rough or it can be cold.
So it's kind of warmed up to about 44, 45 Fahrenheit now.
But I can't do huge distances
'cause I just get really really cold.
And if it's too rough, then I just get beaten up
and I again, can't do huge distances.
So I also have access to a swimming pool
and I'm just wondering, how would you kind of navigate
those two options?
'Cause neither of them is specific to the swim run I'm doing
but you know, would you emphasize the pool?
would you emphasize the sea?
and which would you use for what?
Thanks very much. Bye.
John coming in hot with a vegan swimmer run question.
My favorite kind of question.
Yes and with the great accent right out of the North,
the Northern game of Thrones.
I don't know how far North in England is John.
The North.
Wait is John from the North?
Yeah. Like John Snow.
Is this John Snow?
John Snow is not in England.
First of all. John Snow just learned to swim,
to me the best part of this question is he just learned
to swim three years ago and he's in a swim run.
I love it.
That's amazing. I love that.
Do you want to take a stab at this answer first?
Well I'll let you talk about the best way to train,
since I just kind of wing it.
But I mean, with apologies to Nicholas, I don't wing it,
I do as I'm told, but I do also wing it to some degree.
The one thing I would recommend because of your ocean.
Like for me personally, I like to swim in the ocean.
I don't swim in pools.
But since you're new to swimming I would guess like a lot
of even triathletes that are very good in pools.
They'd often, the transition to getting into open water
is a little bit rougher.
They're not that great or comfortable.
Let's just say they're not as comfortable in open water.
And there is a comfort level of swimming in open water
that you won't have in the, although there will be wind
in a Lake and there might be waves.
It won't be the same thing as a rough sea.
And so if you're going to go into the sea and there's not
a lifeguard on duty and you're swimming alone,
I'd be very cautious at first if you're not comfortable
with it, I would try to swim in tandem at least,
in the open water, especially at those temperatures
that's dangerous and it can be dangerous
if you're not in the right wetsuit.
And so I think that those things, you know, in Hawaii
there's a phrase they have on almost every beach,
"when in doubt don't go out".
And I think it's okay to feel some butterflies
but I don't think it's okay to put yourself
in a dangerous situation.
So I do think you need to be mindful of conditions
and temperature if you're gonna be alone.
And so that's the only thing I would say about the ocean.
Adam drop-in open water safety knowledge
like a true lifeguard, a true Waterman.
So here's what I think.
I think you're going to be fine.
John, kudos for tackling a swim run
three years into learning how to swim.
I think that's ballsy and amazing.
If it makes you feel any better, I trained almost entirely
for the teleswim run world championships in a swimming pool.
I almost never went and open water.
Now, that being said, I have a lot of open-water experience.
So I didn't feel the need to get comfortable on open water.
So what I would say to you is doubled down
on the swimming pool, use that as much as possible
to develop your fitness and your endurance
and your strength.
And you can also use the pool for in and out,
you know, swim run transitions, right?
So in and out swim, run, swim, run, swim, run
get used to swimming and running.
And if you can, if they'll let you at your pool,
swim in the pool with your wetsuit on and your shoes on
because swimming with tennis shoes
is a very strange sensation
that you're going to have to acclimate to.
And if the pool allow you to do it
I would suggest doing that as much as possible.
And of course, using the hand paddles and getting used
to all the gear on all of that is really important.
But I would say that the pool is sub optimal.
You always want to be kind of out
in the natural environment, in terrain that's gonna mimic
the actual race course
and that isn't quite available to you.
So what I would suggest is you avail yourself of the sea
but just pick your moments like once a week
or when the conditions are, you know, fine.
Like I wouldn't go out when it's crazy choppy
or anything like that.
And also 44, 45 degrees is no joke.
So make sure you're wearing an appropriate wetsuit
for that kind of weather.
Five mil at least.
Yeah, get out in the sea and you could do short
swim, run workouts, where you're just, you swim 200 meters
and then run up the shore and, you know, run for a half mile
and then go and then run back into the sea.
So you're not really in the ocean that long
but you're getting used to, you're acclimating
not only to what it feels like to be in open water
but also the weirdness and discomfort of running
up the shore and running back in.
Like developing a comfort level with all of that
from a mental and emotional perspective, I think is huge.
Because if you can handle that,
these lakes are going to be so easy, right?
There'll be no intimidation because you've been out
battling freezing water in the sea.
The lakes of course are not gonna have saltwater.
So there's a different kind of buoyancy thing.
You're not going to be as buoyant.
Like there's something, when you swim in the ocean,
you ride very high in the water
and it actually makes it easier to swim if it's calm.
So the Lake, you're going to ride a little bit lower
and you'll feel a little bit more
like you're fighting the water than you would in the ocean.
But I think you're actually in a great situation
to be mentally prepared because of the conditions
in which you live.
So, pick your moments, the lakes will be easy
after those North sea excursions.
And I don't know what the land terrain is around you.
And I don't know what the terrain of this specific
SwimRun course looks like, but I would,
if I made one mistake and I've said this before
on the podcast in training for Sweden, you know,
I was just running trails and and kind of gradual climbs
and things like that.
And the course in Sweden was very technical.
It was very Rocky.
There was a lot of, actually wasn't that much running.
It was a lot of trudging and climbing up rocks
and things like that.
So, get really familiar with the terrain of the race
and try to find terrain in your natural environment
near your home, where you can mimic
what it's gonna be like during the race.
Yeah, I mean, for me saying, don't go out alone.
I mean, I do go out and swimming alone
but the temperatures are different.
But I will say I was going to ask you Rich.
What do you think about, like since it's a Lake
that he hasn't been in, like how you went to the CRS
to train at altitude and swam in Tahoe,
would you recommend maybe if you have time
and you have the time inclination,
maybe a week excursion, or even just a weekend to a Lake
that you do feel comfortable swimming in.
If he has the ability and the time.
You could drive to some Lake
that maybe is not that far away.
Just for the day or for the weekend or something like that
and get used to experiencing what it's like
to swim in a Lake.
If he hasn't done that before.
That'd be good. Don't you think?
Yeah.
But I promise you if you get comfortable swimming
in the North sea, you're going to be fine in the Lake.
Yeah, you might want to get a seven mil wetsuit
for swimming and it'd be, you know,
unless you're doing swim run and then in case
just get the thickest swim run wetsuit you can get for that.
Yeah.
Cool.
All right.
Cool. All right.
Let's go to our man in Vegas, our German in Vegas.
Hey guys, this is Phillip,
I'm originally from Germany.
I live in Las Vegas now for a year.
I was in a relationship when the pandemic started
and broke things up a couple of weeks ago.
And one of the things that bothered me in the relationship
really was alcohol involved.
And for you Rich, with the experiences you have made,
I have a question.
How are you actually dealing with people
in your surroundings and people in your environment
that have not a real addiction where they get hooked up
on alcohol or things like every single day
but more even, you know, oh, let's have a glass of wine.
And then one glass turns into two or three
and it happens like once a week.
How do you handle people like that?
Because I always had issues with that.
So, yeah.
Thanks for everything you guys do.
You're very inspirational and you helped me
through the hard times and yeah.
Keep up the good work and talk to you soon.
Thanks for your question, Philip.
I suspect that this is probably a more prevalent issue
living in a place like Las Vegas,
than maybe in other locations.
I'm empathetic to the predicament.
But I would say for me it's kind of a double-edged situation
because on the one hand, you know,
I've been sober for a long time
and I'm really just never around people like that anymore.
It's just not part of my inner social circle
like it once was.
But if and when I am around that kind of scenario,
it doesn't really bother me that much
because my sobriety is strong.
It's not like I'm triggered by it.
I can be around people that are drinking
a couple glasses of wine and it doesn't really affect me
in any meaningful way.
Like if it starts getting crazy
and people are getting hammered and stuff like that,
I'll just leave, 'cause it's boring for me.
But it's not like I feel threatened or anything like that.
And the reason I'm not around people like that very much
is that I just don't, I don't seek out those people
or those experiences anymore like I used to.
But when I do encounter them I'm pretty capable
of managing it without incidents.
It doesn't affect your energy.
No, it doesn't affect my energy.
So one question I guess I would have upfront
and I'm curious about is why Philip, it's so bothersome
for you, because you're talking about people
who have maybe two or three glasses of wine once a week.
Which is a pretty, for a lot of people,
like that's a pretty normal thing.
It's not that out of control.
So what is it inside of you
that's getting activated by that?
And if it's just that you don't want to have that
in your environment, then that's cool.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Then that just means that just means you're gonna have
to expand your social circle and find other types of people
to hang out with, or, you know, involve yourself
in like get out to the red rocks or just get, you know,
go to places where it's a different type
of cultural cohesion, where drinking really isn't
so front and center
in terms of how you're interacting socially.
Personally, I'm just not in the business
of taking anyone else's inventory.
So I don't sit in judgment of somebody who wants to have
two or three glasses of wine.
But, and I would say this to you.
Like we do have choices as to who we spend our time with.
And I think in my experience the best way of managing
this kind of situation if you're just not enthusiastic
about being with people who are into that right now,
you don't have to make a big statement about it
or a manifesto about how you're not going to stand
for this anymore.
You could just back away slowly from that environment.
And I think of it in terms of concentric rings of intimacy.
So if you think of yourself in the middle
and then there's a bunch of circles outside of you
that expand.
Who is in that inner ring?
And those would be the people that you trust the most,
you trust implicitly.
Then the next ring of people would be people
who maybe are just more casual friends
and it kind of goes out from there.
So, I'm constantly thinking about the people that I keep
in that inner circle, and then the people who get moved
to outer rings because something else happens.
And you have the ability to slowly transition
your social time to more like-minded people
who are aligned with your social habits.
And you can move those, you know, you can move away
from those people or those people just get
kind of slowly pushed out to a different rate.
It doesn't mean that you can't be friends with them anymore.
It's just that the dynamic of your friendship
might get tweaked a little bit.
And it doesn't have to be that big a deal.
And I would also say that it's important, you know,
on the subject of not taking anyone's inventory
or making a big deal in terms of how you,
you don't have to proclaim this to anybody.
I think it's important to have compassion for the fact that
it's been a fucking hard year for a lot of people.
And certain people are going to be like, I wanna have two
or three glasses of wine.
And if they can do that and they're happy with their life,
that's their business.
It's not mine to judge.
So I tend to air on giving people a break
and giving people some latitude and understanding
that we all have different ways of coping
with the various anxieties and stressors that we face.
But ultimately this is about your relationship with you.
And I think it's incumbent upon you to stop focusing
on what others are doing or being upset
because people aren't behaving in a manner
that you would prefer them to behave.
Stop grinding on why they aren't doing things your way
and just focus more on your path and your choices
and the people that you choose to spend time with.
Well said.
Is there anything else to say on that?
I don't think so. I think you've covered it.
You know, there you go.
Are we done? do you think anyone's still listening?
I think there's a couple of guys behind that curtain.
Yeah. They're being paid, paid to listen.
They have to, they can't leave yet.
You know what, thank you for having me.
Thank you for coming here.
Thank you for being appropriately available.
Well, I might've, is it appropriate to camp out here
the night before?
Probably not.
Okay. Well, I'm glad I chose not to this time.
Did you bring your mask?
God, you know what, here's the thing.
I'm gonna be nice to you.
I'm supposed to be nice to you.
I'm not gonna be mean to you.
Here's the thing.
This area I'm sure has a lot of this going on.
I should have led with this.
The coyotes are making love outside my apartment
on a regular basis now.
And it's on the next door and everything
and they're all talking about
and that it's a very strange howling.
I would imagine there's some coyote lovemaking
happening around here,
Quite a bit.
Quite a bit at night, you hear it at night.
Did you know they were in heat right now?
Is that a thing?
No, I didn't know that.
Yeah. That's what's happening.
That's what's happening?
Yes.
They tend to run down the middle of the road,
in front of our house in packs.
And if people who haven't experienced this,
it's like a loud screeching noise.
Yes.
It's rather alarming.
It's different than the normal yipping.
No, like it doesn't sound like a wolf for a dog
or something like that.
It sounds like there's some periodization happening
in the coyote community.
And right now is the period to have fun.
They are leaving in alignment with their circadian rhythms
in close proximity to nature.
The right to spring my friends.
Although I did wake up in the tent the other morning.
And there was a bird on top of the tent that was pecking
at the roof and tearing a hole in the roof of my tent.
Oh my goodness.
Maybe it was trying to collect some hair parts.
And I don't know what kind of bird it was, but I darted up
and it's scurried away and there's like a hole in my tent.
But you're not in the roof still, you moved.
No, I'm on the ground.
So now I have to be a little bit more cautious
about making sure it's zipped up and there's no snakes
or anything like that.
Interesting.
No snacks in the tent.
The tent.
Yeah.
Did you fix the tent yet?
Is it a double wide?
I've got to check, but here's my thing.
I want to get like a glamping tent, like a cool.
Right, a cabana.
I need to explore that a little bit.
I want a tent that rivals the house.
Like a big, flowing white number.
Yeah. That's what I want.
You're going to come out and build the deck for me.
A Mongolian.
Because you're so available.
A Mongolian worthy of Gangas Kahn.
That's what I want.
I don't want a yard,
but they do have these really cool glamping tents.
There's a company in Topanga actually
that makes some pretty cool ones.
I'm gonna go check out.
Yeah. So more will be revealed.
Well, thank you for having me.
Thank you for being here my friend.
Hope you guys enjoyed.
I don't know what this was about.
I guess we, what are we calling this?
We're calling this periodize your life.
I think that's the title of this podcast.
Be the coyote.
You feel good, I feel good.
Yeah, man.
Cool, man.
All right, we'll be back in two weeks.
In the meantime follow Adam at Adam Skolnick.
You can follow me at Rich Roll.
Leave us a message with your question
and we just might answer it at (424) 235-4626.
You can check out the show notes and links
to everything we discussed today
on the episode page at richroll.com.
Don't forget to subscribe to the show on YouTube, Apple,
Spotify, all the places.
Also, we recently,
not that recently,
we created a clips channel on YouTube.
It kind of went fallow, bringing that fallow word back.
That's sort of the recurring word of the day, I think,
fallow, it went fallow for a period of time
because we just didn't have the manpower,
the editing manpower to service it.
But I'm happy to announce that we've got AJ on board
brand new hire, shout out to AJ, who's come on board
to focus on creating clips for the clips channel.
We're gonna be uploading two videos a day.
All right.
Clips channel going forward.
Including clips from the Roll on, of course the questions,
all that kind of stuff.
So it would mean a lot, especially if you dig short chunks
from the show or just want to sample I guess
before committing.
If you would check out our clips channel
and subscribe to it.
You can find it on YouTube if you just search
Rich Roll podcast clips.
Of course we'll have a link in showing us to that as well.
But I really want to build out this clips channel.
I'm excited about AJ manning that dashboard
and getting some activity there and bringing it
out of its fallow state into full bloom.
Welcome AJ, cool.
Thanks everybody who helped put on the show today,
Jason Camiola, for audio engineering production show notes
and interstitial music.
Blake Curtis and Margo Lubin who handle video
and editing for the show.
And of course, AJ now on the clips channel.
Jessica Miranda for graphics.
We don't have anybody shooting portraits today.
We're going photo free today, I feel naked.
Georgia Whaley for copywriting.
DK for advertiser relationships and theme music
as always by my boys, Tyler Trapper and Harry.
Appreciate all you guys see you back here
in a couple of days with another awesome episode.
Episode 602 coming in hot,
602, unbelievable.
All right, man.
Thanks brother.
Thank you.
Piece.